baby baby everybody you had to be the most ready because you
started before any of us really
No, no, no, we're here to bully sure for the only non-BT for
here.
Right, right, right.
You guys literally can't bully me.
That's not bullying.
That's just a challenge.
Well, you want me to start talking about touching my balls?
I don't think so.
We're just concerned about your health.
I'm the one that's being tame here.
I am suppressing myself.
Balls on.
Boy.
You want me to take my.
balls out whoa this is a medical check here sure for i can
talk about my five steps ahead i'm gonna talk about my my
constipation for a while like now it's your turn hey go for
it this is a health stream now this is a health check we
want to make sure everybody is medically okay there is
nothing you could say that would make me uncomfortable
Do it.
I dare you.
All right, Lily, do it.
Say something.
But don't go for European.
Anil warts.
What?
Yeah, what about it?
Got them.
Got them all.
You got some of those?
Oh, hello.
Oh.
What about it, Lily?
Why did that give us your first thing you want to say?
Do you have something to tell us?
I don't know.
I'm, I just figured I, okay, I guess we're not really on the
same wavelength here.
Oh, okay.
I just thought that maybe, you know, maybe you're just
coincidentally.
googled for absolutely no reason whatsoever what it's like
to have them why did you google in awards for me what it
might be like i i wasn't yeah yeah at all can you explain
into the class i wasn't seeing any suspicious growth it's
it's all right i hope you started at all and not images how
do you even see them yeah how do you oh wait are they inside
wait Maybe I was just investigating my health.
That's the blowhole blast.
Can you buy one of those doctor equipments?
She's got a camera and like a tube.
Oh, no.
Loki, that's what you do with the prize money.
What the fuck?
How did you know?
That would be so funny.
Are you going to make a stream just dedicated to that?
I need to defend.
Okay, okay, okay.
But if you had one of those, which hole would you stick it
in first?
I think nose will be so funny.
Nose?
The nose.
Because, like, it's, like, weird.
And, okay, maybe that's just me, but if you stick it up your
butt, it's, like, what do you expect?
Like, you kind of know what to expect.
But, like, the nose, it's, like, it's full of, like, hairs,
and, like, maybe it's tiny, but maybe it's also just, like,
a fat boogie.
Like, it's full of surprises, man.
If the camera is small enough, you can stick it down the
edge of your eye.
Oh, goodness.
Whoa.
The end.
Straighten slime, no thanks.
Oh.
look for my last eyelashes oh my god you know when you have
eyelashes in your eye you wrap it and suddenly it's gone
it's like well that's just in the back of my eye forever now
dude i never thought about it where do they go right but i
feel like it's biodegradable isn't it they get disintegrated
yeah it's like when there's when there's bugs that randomly
fly into your eyes no no they just get disintegrated oh boy
oh boy it's have the furnace yeah bugs have bugs fly into
People's eyes all the time.
Okay.
I did a lot of it.
I was bicycling a lot.
I was like little fucking bugs in my eyes.
Like, that's just a nature massage.
I don't want them.
How do we get here?
How the fuck did we...
Guys, how about we...
Oh, we got here because you tried to make me uncomfortable.
Let's get...
Let's talk about the stress that we're gonna be doing for
day two, everybody.
That's boring.
Why don't we tell our chat what we're planning on doing for
day two?
day two everyone that is just like i can't believe i got up
early for this my condolences but you kind of knew what you
were signing up for don't pretend come on look at this look
at look at these look at these people all right look at them
what do you mean these people yeah what do you mean lily
these people one of us is a little big bugger
That's so rude!
That's discrimination!
Live on stream?
I can't believe it!
I can see the twit longers.
I can sense them.
Oh my god.
Anyway, so our jobs today, Shore4 is our, as always, power
leveler he is the tank of the group he's gonna be catching
all the hard pals I will be focused on the medium pals and
also like catching all the ingredients for the food Lily is
the ball master she's gonna be the ball master and Pippi
will be the bass master so and she's gonna be working on
doing all the bass stuff yep and so yeah that is our job at
the two hour mark we're gonna be doing dungeon runs and then
one hour mark we're gonna be petting some pals so like just
to make sure we all remember that wait when are we doing the
are we doing the the faction towers too at this as well uh
after the dungeons should we do them as a group or singular
i mean if you could do it singular do it i mean the first
one should be easiest yeah i can do this first one i can
focus on the first tower honestly i can do that right now
because yeah and then we can figure out the other towers
after on a two-hour mark when we're doing the dungeons oh
yeah so anyway that's our plan we actually have a plan this
time well we we're not going in super blind all right guys i
believe in us to be still top 10 after this oh yeah easy
easy yeah yeah we didn't do any of the global points so
that's the that's the great part we're just power level yeah
we're trusting the process just trust the process also like
we know that legendaries are like 360 points but sure for
was like there's no way we can get it maybe it's just
because i maybe it's just because i was playing the game of
the hardest difficulty maybe it's easier now me oh we've we
check try it later like at the one hour mark and see if we
can catch any legendaries also also the admin wants to see
your world settings
okay you're asking for it oh yeah we're supposed to start in
one minute like aren't we oh wait no they're starting the
checking and the checks in one minute all right cool cool
cool I'm scrolling up and down he's trying his best I'm
scrolling up and down I think we should figure out the
breeding stuff too like if we have the pals for it when
we're in oh my goodness PP I just saw your freaking twitch
rivals image I mean Wait, that's so adorable.
I also drew Shure 4.
Wait, what was...
Wait, you drew this?
The character's name is like Chisumi?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Chisumi?
That is so cute.
That's so cute.
It's Chisumi?
Chisumi?
My alt account in Overwatch.
Ah.
Sorry I doxxed you on main.
Oh, that's fine.
You know, he has a V-tuber model too.
Yeah, he's a V-tuber.
He doesn't, but he refused to be a V-tuber.
I'm used to it once.
He's too scared.
He's a coward All right, turn it on then.
Why don't you turn it on that chat your streamer's a vtuber
You think I have my fucking shit set up right now You know
what fair chat sure for chat.
How do you feel that you're your streamers of part-time
vtuber?
How do you feel about that?
Are you expecting me to like respond for you like?
Like, you're asking my...
Are you, like, looking at it right now?
What's going on here?
I think I can start the world, right?
Your chat does not.
We need the code.
Yeah, we need the code.
Wait, you're ready a furry?
When were you a furry?
I was never a furry.
Then why is your chat saying you're a furry?
They call me a scaly because I like dragons.
Don't hide the truth.
Don't hide, yeah.
Embrace your truth.
embrace who you are embrace your truth don't be scared i'm
one of the most truthful people you ever meet if i was a
furry i would just say it yeah but isn't a scaly also a
furry yeah but i'm not a scaly either but you just like drag
listen so dragon girls and cat girls are not on the furry
scale yes they are how they not in the furry scale they have
the ears and tail is fine That's when you start getting
furry There's like but then there's like a degree.
It's like a spectrum.
It's like a furry spectrum I think you're so smart you think
you're so smart.
What's 25 plus 25, huh?
Where the fuck is our world code?
Is that a trick question?
No, it's a math.
math question.
No way.
Not gonna trick me into doing math on a Saturday.
Just establish.
Damn.
All right, I'm joining the lobby.
I'm in the world.
I'm in the world too.
Yeah, why don't you answer his math question?
Are you too stupid?
That's fucked up, dokey.
What?
I'm asking a question!
Why is that fucked up?
I was just asking a question!
I'm just repeating what you said, but like in different, I'm
rewording it so I don't please your eyes.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Girl, stop.
Guys, you're supposed to play a video game.
Okay, so they said they said they said don't do anything and
we're not allowed to do anything But but like we're about to
get invaded What do we do?
What do we do?
We're gonna get invaded.
Tell the admins we're literally getting invaded.
We are being invaded.
We are being raided.
We have to fight back!
We can't we can't really uh...
It's away, but it's the tacos!
I know we need tacos too!
Oh wait, I've already killed them.
Wait, never mind, they're on their way, they're on their
way.
Oh, I have to close the server.
Oh my gosh.
Oh shit.
Wait, I thought they said everything was good.
I thought you said once you checked in, you can start the
server.
I also thought once you checked in.
I thought so too, they were like, okay, just log in, but
don't leave.
Like not already did.
Server is closed anyways.
Problem solved.
We solved it, guys!
We closed the server.
Did they check the settings?
I don't know, man.
We didn't do anything.
I thought we were in the green to start.
We were shocked.
Wait, they were like, no, they're giving conflicting
information.
The admins don't even know.
Listen, all I'm saying is he's...
He was saying, please wait for our communication.
The last time he didn't told us we got checked and we
started late.
And then but then the person beneath it was like now if
you're being raided, you can fight so technically We don't
need the closest server Who's right?
Who's the alpha admin?
All right, tell me now we can start now we can start the
world Okay, all right, it's the same code Yeah, it made a
big difference.
No session found though.
I need the code.
We need the code.
Yeah, no session found because I'm stuck It now we're late
again.
No, we have three minutes to start.
You don't have time yet.
We can do it We just can't catch them.
I chill.
Well, the raid's gone because I powered games.
Okay.
Nice Nice we exploited We didn't exploit we legally
exploited I It's a legal exploit.
It's a feature.
It was yeah.
Oh, you're right.
It's a feature legal exploit because we illegally started
but then legally turned it off wait but then no but yeah we
can yeah now my game crashed move down
we're being punished hey i just leveled up from doing
nothing let's go okay all right i'm i'm joining back again
Don't worry.
Come back in.
Keeps telling.
Okay.
You guys aren't allowed to touch anything when you look.
We're just here to check.
Unless we get raided, then we can kill, but not.
Then we can fight.
All right.
I'm back in.
It's okay.
I don't even have my gear.
I hope the toos come back.
Oh, boy.
We need them.
Why is everybody...
Wait, everyone is sick.
What did you do to our pals?
Everyone's sick.
What happened?
Who the fuck did this to our pals?
condition yeah we have fluffy beds okay look i'm not i have
two fluffy beds i am no fountain i'm in i'm in charge of the
power base who the fuck did this look look i was busy dude
our cat fucking is stuck we're not a lot to help her yet
it's all right i'm getting i'm getting rid of the beds today
i hope we just have to watch our catchers are stuck we're
unable to do anything legally.
We actually, we need to make the giant pal bed today really,
really quickly, really right after this.
That is your job.
We need to figure out what we need.
Okay, we need a Mastandra for the breeding and also the I
mean, you got the Nubus stuff all done, right?
We're good with the Nubus breeding, right?
Probably.
I need to check gender.
And then we just need a Mastandra.
I have a male Pen King.
I have a female bushy, but I need a male penking.
I have a male penking because I've caught one.
Let me got it.
Yeah, I caught one from the boss.
I'm pretty sure he's a guy.
I need the bee.
Yeah, I can put that too.
So we can get some honey.
I'll put the bee and the penking in the thing.
Who do I take out, though?
Does anybody have the cow as well?
I have a cow.
Oh, then we can put that in, too.
Oh, yeah, I've got a cow as well.
Where was the dock?
The Google dock posting again?
give it to you just like recently are you talking about for
the which google doc the achievement or okay i can give you
that yeah you can start okay we can start now okay let's go
i can put okay i have a cow just take out whatever you don't
need and i'll fill a slot of the cow okay i'm putting in my
mail i'll just throw the cow in um okay perfect all right
where the did i put the penguin we also need to get tomato
seeds uh lettuce seeds and i think I think we probably
already have wheat seeds.
I'm getting rid of the...
Do I get rid of the chick monk?
Which one do I get rid of?
Um, chip monk is worthless.
You can get rid of it.
Okay, and then...
Uh...
And then I'll put in the key guard.
Where the fuck is this fucker?
I know I caught you.
They're like sleeping, so they're like...
Wait, who do you want me to get rid of?
I don't know which one to get rid of.
We get rid of the cat...
Cat tiva or whatever.
Yeah, I got it.
Put...
They're in.
Alright.
Let me fix my stuff.
Alright, once it's daytime...
I need the cool dog I put it in the chat oh nice yeah I'm
freezing to death my loot is in Brazil whoa oh shit welcome
to Brazil I died I need more fucking balls soon okay I'm
gonna put all this stuff away let's see actually I think
it's worth getting did I have anything oh yeah remember to
make more furnaces We need to make more furnaces.
See?
I'm about to just make a bunch of iron on this island over
here.
I'm stealing this ball.
Thank you.
I have a lot of mats if people want.
I'm gonna make another chest to put these mats in.
I think I'm gonna make a chest to sort stuff a bit more
efficiently because it'll take so much time to go through
all the chests.
Let's see.
So I'm gonna redo the chest if anyone wants.
honey i put the ice organs too i and then yeah if you want
to resort stuff you can what the fuck see half the reason
they're getting trapped is because the this like piece of
like the cliff we're on is made out of this stone that they
can fall through no you're so fucking stupid no it's not our
fault they're pretty it's just our pals are pretty stupid
it's not our fault all right i'm just gonna send it over
here all right let's see I have to do...
What do I have to do again?
Alright, I'm gonna go start killing some pals.
I'm just gonna try to put them further apart so that they
don't get stuck on each other.
Okay, I make one big chest, which is just like common
materials.
So whenever you come to the base real quick, you can just
dump all your like common shit in there.
Alright, I'm gonna get the mozzarella meat for us.
And then...
Okay, it should have enough storage for everything dumped.
Okay, I'm gonna try to get this shell off the...
Well, I should get a misandra right now for us, actually.
I feel like that'd be the easiest.
Because we need a misandra.
Alright, I need to grab this bee.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, put the bee in the right pouch.
We fly.
Where am I?
I went the wrong way again.
We fly.
my son yeah i'm coming over we only need for the rest of the
base building home let me take a look we only actually need
uh okay we still need 250 ingot but once we get 250 ingot
after that it all just becomes refined ingot so we need to
stop making like a crap ton unless we need it for other
things oh we need the ingots for the balls so yeah balls i
guess we'll just keep trying to meet the buzz all right
where am i i need 300 380 ore for the refined ones for the
base just make more furnaces yeah just make more furnaces
over here okay i'm about to make a lot of ore over here all
right that's what we need okay i need to go set up the the
coal base so i'll go do that what gender do we need for the
massandra um massandra what is the pedal pedal one the
patalia that you caught what was the gender of it female
okay i'll catch a male okay all right i don't know if i my
game crashed why is it crashing what the let me back in guys
i think i might need a new pc just make a bunch of iron over
here maybe
Please I was Or you can mind a bunch of iron over here Chat
you heard them they need a new PC Get on it.
Put it here first new PC.
Get on it.
Top top.
I bet a 4080.
Why is this keep happening?
Maybe it's too good.
It's too good.
You're right.
It's just too good of a PC No, what the fuck you can't do
this weird is the cow you put it out.
I don't see it.
I'm just gonna respawn it He's somewhere oh I think this
base that they always walk like a really weird path and
they're like like five bases ahead they're just walking
they're like goodbye they're just it's just too good our
base is just good you know like where is she going or but
it's yeah why the pals just need better walk cycles sounds
like a pal problem come on powered you heard that it's not
our fault it's By the way, thanks for, like, sponsoring this
tournament, by the way.
Love the game, though.
Keep at it.
Love the game, bud.
Love the game, but anyway, it's your fault.
Okay, well, I took the beds off the rock for the most part,
so they should get stuck in the rock.
Okay, there's two.
There's a male and a female, but we'll kill.
Oh my goodness, why is he stuck up there?
My eight arrows.
You can do this.
Go, Vanuil.
What are we using the boar for?
I think he's mining.
The miners?
Okay.
Upgrading base.
Okay, that's the female.
We don't care about the female.
Oh, God.
Please.
I need these.
Thank you.
All right.
We don't need electricity yet.
We're going to.
Who is a builder?
All right.
This is going to be rough.
No, Kuri Rack!
Leave me alone!
build okay i got i got i got milk missandra i got mail
missandra yeah you can't build okay nice okay we basically
have what we needed for uh for the other breeding all right
i want to set up the the breeding before oh wait oh the heck
can build the cake all right for the cake for the cake i
need flour i need berries i need milk and i need egg all
right we need Does anybody have any eggs on them?
Yeah, I put a lot of eggs in the chest.
Nice.
I think?
I think so.
I trust.
Look, there's something in there.
Uh...
If there's no eggs, we can just kill some chickens.
Yeah, we can kill chickens or I can throw one in the ranch
maybe.
Alright, I need to find a fast traveler.
What the fuck are you doing over here?
I have... I caught a masandra so you can breed it at any
time you want.
Nice.
Let it have a good time.
Oh yeah, sure.
Remember to put a patalia in the...
in the base whenever you have time.
I'm using her right now.
What?
Why you gotta say it like that?
What are you using her for?
She's in my party.
Mm-hmm.
And what is her purpose in your party?
To break it.
Where the fuck is he?
It's a fast travel.
It was one.
Okay, I'll make a barrel at the base and that barrel will
have the spheres all the time.
Yes, I need some giga spears right now.
Can we make a conveyor belt already?
I think we need circuit boards for that though.
Yeah, we just...
If we can build a...
Oh, well, we have a...
Oh, yeah, we need to make the power generation.
Yeah, we need circuit boards.
Like, right away.
Yeah, I think...
We're all at the level to make them.
Yeah, we just...
We need the quartz.
That's literally...
What's the dungeon we need to do?
Mountain stream grotto?
Do we need that?
I'm gonna check.
Mountain...
Oh, no.
No, we don't.
It's sacred.
No, I check.
volcanic and sacred mountain yeah i just checked it's not
this one all right we need i need more gigaspir right now i
only have four i'm just gonna go build the coal base i only
have four lily where are my fire pales where are my balls
lily oh here uh here's some balls in the in the what's it
called the barrel in the middle of the base okay i'll steal
this one too from yeah Nice.
He's trying his best to make more.
I'm gonna steal it right now.
I just need more ingots and then I can start making more.
Alright, that should be enough for now.
Oh my god, bro!
Where are they?
Alright, do you want me to put the Masandra in now or later?
Uh, into the breeding?
We don't have cake yet.
Uh, yeah, but do you want me to just put it in, put it in
there for now?
I'll just stay here.
I'm gonna replace the Dino one since...
it in my yeah i put it i replaced the dino just in case okay
cool uh i'm gonna do the faction tower now i'm gonna do the
tower yeah i want to start breeding but we don't have cake
so how do we make cake uh you need honey and milk and egg oh
eggs i can give you guys eggs now yeah i'll go get yeah
you're just missing eggs right yeah i'm just well i'm
missing honey the bee will not stay in the ranch for some
reason just chuck him in some honey i'll take honey if you
got it i'm gonna get i'm gonna kill some chickens real quick
i'm gonna go build the cold little chicken do you need to
research cement cement cement is made out of bone pal fluid
and uh stone i need to research it uh it's one of the things
yeah you can't see it in the tech tree we've been blind it
should be let me see oh i just need insta kill him we'll
ride cement is level 19.
yeah you guys should be able stone structures now as well
chicken where are you chicken oh i'm gonna kill you stop
eating go back to work stop eating you can't eat when you
when you work for it yeah that's right you didn't earn the
food you didn't earn the food yeah you heard her you can eat
when you die i'm starving too Fuck, fuck, wait, I'm also
starving, wait I'm gonna- oh, I'm saying that you gotta
preach it.
Uh, uh, I earned it, surely, right?
Wait, what did you do?
Oh, wait, can somebody give me- Do we have all the Tombats
out right now?
I wanna take one to the new base.
I have two of it.
Yeah.
Okay, can you put another one on- on base?
I'll just take this one.
Yeah, I can.
I just need to fucking pick up- No, you're hungry.
Why are you hungry?
You can starve when I tell you to.
Stop starving.
Stop starving now.
Stop it.
I need water pals.
Okay.
I can give you some water pals if you need it.
I'll throw it at Surfit.
Alright.
I got 16 eggs.
I'm putting the eggs in the...
I'll put the eggs in the chest.
You should have enough.
now right with the eggs oh unless you're missing something
you still need honey but maybe we have a lot of honey like i
put some honey too in the honey in one of the chest i put
like three at least three in there what do you mean i'll be
assigned i'll take a look you have no permission to start
what the guy
what all right i am stop yeah there's three honey at least
in there and there's six There's 43 eggs too.
Okay, okay.
Then I can probably cook.
Make sure you're using the Dormantide Ignis for smelting.
What the fuck?
Oh yeah.
We have the Instagram just doing it right now.
Let's see.
Oh yeah.
I'm gonna go do the...
I'm gonna go do the faction tower for real this time.
Aye, good luck.
Alright, let's make a mill.
you should put the if you're not gonna use the egg right
away you should put in a cooler yes because that the eggs
are the the eggs is in the but but but it's oh fuck i forgot
to get the arrows it is in the chest the three chests that's
like on the cliff it's in one of them cool oh over here okay
yeah i don't think you you don't have to take it out let me
see if i can actually already just make the cake you don't
have to take the materials out we need milk i've got to make
flour okay i'll make any extra arrows anywhere on the bench
there's 363 i'm gonna i'm going to make mine it's mine now
all right i moved the the chest all right get the tower get
ready to clip this when i defeat this tower also remember to
yell clip it clip it when we when we remember to yell clip
it clip it so we remember to clip it clip it so we remember
to clip it clip it thank you wait shout out to my mods thank
you so much for clipping everything yesterday you're the
realist hell yeah all right let me in them they now have a
nickname thanks to doki tuna they're not called the peepie
mods the peepie which which sounds like which sounds like
something that should be outlawed everywhere but florida but
you know it's fine all right here we kill this guy he's like
fucking what level is he i'm gonna reset these go go they
should probably run into less now oh no please leave me
alone i need an open line no wait we're the wood and the
palladium cry girl what the stop i'm killing the faction zoe
and what level is this what is level is the second tower
boss you guys know 30 i never done that 30 okay so yeah i
haven't done that i only got to the first one and then like
the first one and i'm just yeah i'm like i'm done i'm good i
played three days non-stop and then i was like i'm good i'm
good to go i feel like the bosses just aren't like as worth
it in this game yeah compared to similar games that we won't
name.
I think it's just because, like, I guess it's like Dark
Souls-esque, too.
So it's like...
Yeah.
But like, it's not as...
We're warding to kill them.
Yeah.
Oh, another thing.
If you see any electric, that's, like, large electric eggs,
that's another way to get Grisbolt that is, like, less of a
hassle if anybody has any.
I have, I don't have one.
All right.
Well, if you guys see any priority on that one.
Okay.
Mill.
No.
Don't kill me.
Vanworm, please!
Stop!
Oh my god.
My vanworm got stuck.
I need that.
Maybe I should not use a vanworm.
Maybe I should use a sweeper.
No, why are you hungry?
You're not allowed to starve!
Stop starving!
I didn't tell you!
Please.
What a gloomongo!
Hello?
Hi.
What are you?
Stop building!
Get the fucking butt here!
These fucking pals!
These pals are gold-craft balls!
Fuck!
Wait, I've got- I've got on you.
What did I not pay- this is not what I paid you for because
you're not getting paid in general.
Yeah, you don't really get paid, but...
You're allowed to survive if you make balls.
Yeah.
Earn your food.
Your use to me is your ball production.
Don't worry, they're gonna be able to make balls faster in a
second.
Oh yeah, this is Assembly line.
Let's go.
Finally.
Assembly line.
Clip this clip.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
Boss eliminated.
Clip, clip, clip.
Let's go.
Clip, clip.
I need a bunch of balls.
We all do.
We're on it.
We all need balls.
All right, what do I... Okay.
Let's see.
What else do we need?
I can try and catch a ray hound.
You can't catch a grisbolt, right?
Unless we go to the sanctuary, right?
Can you catch a grisbolt?
I have no idea either.
Yeah, we need a grisbolt.
Yeah, but can we catch a grisbolt?
But in the sanctuary, yes.
Yes?
But I don't know what level the sanctuary is.
Okay, I'm just gonna go to the desert and catch a hound.
I pallium fragments hold up should have helped the flow
around here how much rock do we have there's a way to easily
get not much oh yeah yeah with the crusher yeah no you go to
the rains you go to rain syndicate tower and then you just
teleport to the cave and there's a big ore nodes in there oh
okay and every cave there's oh yeah yeah so we just find a
dungeon right yeah yep All right, let's see.
What do I need to do now?
I got one of the towers done.
I'm not leveled up for the medium bosses yet.
Let's see.
What levels are the marketeers?
For the lowest level one I know is 40.
40?
Okay, I'm not in range for that yet.
I'm going to get a heat-resistant armor and catcher right
hound for us.
um okay i don't have the crafting yet for that let's see
where are you he resistant pelt armor quick get the cold
resistant pelt armor here okay uh i need more ingots where
i'm gonna help bring my van worm here van worm ingots now
ingots go go van worm okay my van worm is doing ingots
because i need that shit i'll farm some ore for us too uh
now that we have the just the assembly line do we still need
the sphere wrench i don't think we do no don't think so no
all right then i'll just nuke it
okay all right cool i just need my i need like 40 ingots so
i can make the heat resistant armor thank you penking for
the flower i think i just need to go collect milk now and we
have enough for cake work work my precious cow i was hoping
we have everything we need our pals need like like four more
beds by the way why do we have beds for them if they have no
baths and one sleep and they were working guys one has ulcer
what are you doing to our pals no time to cure the ulcer we
can replace them you replace the world manage your ulcer
yourself our comfy does not cover medical costs no insurance
this is a north American Tournament, baby.
I feel like a North American Tournament does cover for
medical costs.
Maybe half.
If you're lucky.
Where the fuck is the repair?
Do we have any medicine?
No, we don't even have a medicine bar.
Oh, wait.
I have some medicine.
Hold on.
Wait a minute.
Let's see.
I'm trying to put away...
I'm putting away...
Mining away.
I don't know what's left of mine, I mine it anyways.
It's Minecraft world, so beautiful.
Nice.
That was beautiful, guys.
Mine diamonds!
What will you do a karaoke stream, Sheriff for?
You have the voice for it.
I wonder where I feel like it.
Why won't you give your Chad karaoke?
I need to find a way to give reverb on my voice.
That's how you sound nice.
You can just do reverb.
Yeah.
Okay, how do I do that?
It's so just get a go XLR.
Last time I got a go XLR, I plugged that shit in and
downloaded the software, and nothing worked, and I was too
lazy, so I gave it.
Why would you mean nothing worked?
I don't know.
I was pressing buttons.
There's no thing.
I don't know how to make the noises.
There's no thang.
No thang just sticking out.
Just watch a YouTube tutorial.
I found a solution to our fox having an ulcer.
I replaced him with a different fox.
We don't need him anyway.
Medical carrot.
No, thank you.
We're just replacing him.
Holy fuck.
It's okay.
We'll get a scab.
Is that it?
Welcome to capitalism.
Scabs are allowed in this company.
Jesus Christ I've been mining this whole time Oh, I thought
you were supposed to power it level Yeah, I need balls for
that.
I'm gonna try to collect a bunch of shit I'm heading to
catch a right hound now.
Oh Sick, we got another bushy All right All right, come over
here.
It's right hound time Am I heading the right way?
Does anybody have any eggs incubators empty?
Nope, no, I'm not on me.
There might be one in the chest.
Oh, yeah, we don't have electricity.
We got one common.
So, like, we can't make balls anymore.
We can have electricity already.
I can make one right now.
Yeah.
Hell yeah, brother.
Oh, wait, no, we need 100 ingot.
That's what I was waiting for.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
We need it, though, so...
Just make more furnaces.
That's our, like, only answer to make more...
We don't even have enough firepower to take care of the
furnace and make more.
Should we?
We should...
No, it's kind of a waste of mats.
I was gonna say we can make the better furnace, but we might
as well just wait until we can make the electric furnace.
We should like...
How much are we from leveling up the base?
What do we need for base level?
Right now for a base level up...
Give me a second.
We need the power generators, so we need...
I'm just waiting on the ingot.
Okay.
so if we can hold off on balls for a second i just need to i
need 50 ingots here that's sure for we need 50 i need the
balls i need the balls i can't level right now i can't level
i have to kill everything where the fuck are the what about
my balls i have a heat resistant armor now i just need to
find the rye hounds rye hounds where are you uh is the wheat
ready yet yes cool okay i can start breeding what are you
trying to make with the ingots uh i need to make the power
generator so i need 50 or do i need to go for it yeah i have
41 i think we need more mining pals we're kind of behind on
rock and stuff agree i think you have to mine at yourself at
this point it would be really the mining pals don't dig like
at all they're like if we can get the dig toys can't we do
the can't we dig toys we need to catch them in the desert
yeah isn't dick toys still bugged they're bugged every every
mind pal is bugged they don't i thought they were a turtle
that's oh yeah everybody in my chat says dig toys bad okay
yeah it's super buggy right now dig toys is good if you use
it yourself yeah yeah but not as like mine well no pal is
good at mining like yeah it's just they're all trying to
make auto yeah trying to make auto farms is useless right
now in this game i might land with like a different like
mining pal it works so well like it doesn't respawn fast
enough for them to have much to do well you actually got
your pals to collect all the yeah like it works flawless
it's just a eu div it's
you guys it would have worked whenever i had my pals trying
to collect stuff they would just pick it up drop it pick it
up drop it and there just be giant piles everywhere i think
it just depends on how your base is set up too because i
have had problems with like pals picking up my shit because
i made a very specific base to yeah avoid all the passing
issues like uh i build like walls and pathways and stuff
specifically cake all right we made our first cake nice now
bleed i guess we'll start with anubis because he's the most
useful for the base i'm handing over to can anubis mine uh
anubis can do handiwork and then you can replace the
breeding pals too because some of them are useless anyway
i'm handing over to this waypoint where the is the rye hound
i need a female rye hound right Because we have a male
massager.
Yeah, if we're going to make Grisbold that way.
Yeah, I can't find him.
Oh, I made the electric thing.
Oh, you made it already?
Nice.
Okay, cool.
Now I just need a pal that can power it.
Oh, wait, you made it?
Is it being built?
Okay, okay.
Thanks.
I'm trying to find the Rai Hound wherever you are.
Wait, Anubis also has mining.
We might want to consider making more than one Anubis.
Just to get the mining.
all right control because it slows down the ball the ball
production a ton i have to just like mine manually the whole
time i'm just trying to find our little dog in this sad
world out here yeah i feel like the base being 50 on newbies
is like actually the play yeah honestly like we just breed a
couple of them real quick make electrical and then some
handy work The rest is mining.
That will solve all the ball issues.
Oh, that would, yeah.
Honestly.
Oh, my God, Lily, you're brainstorming.
I'm brainstorming.
Your brain is enlarging right now.
I'm doing it.
My game crashed.
All right, next one.
No.
Why?
I'm cursed right now.
Someone cursed my game.
I just want the right hand.
please let me in where am i okay uh high quality hot springs
we need uh so when you start making cement uh i can make
cement i can't make this hot springs though and we need a
weapon assembly line so whoever's level 32 and 31 i can get
to level 32 soon after i i will make cement sure for at the
moment sure for has the boss he needs to hurry and power
level i have no balls that's the problem do we not are we
not at range yet for the ingots well we need power and then
we also need this and we need that oh my god we need so many
things and we need this and that let me add the right area
for fucking and new the right hounds I haven't found a
single right hound um I put their location on the dock but I
don't know yeah like the like am I I'm pretty sure I'm in
the area for it yeah this has to be the area for the fucking
right hands chat am i in the right area i can never tell
anymore all i see is tacos and you'll never freaking know
i'll never know the cake takes so freaking long to cook
probably oh apparently it's daytime only okay that makes
sense.
Do we want a daisy?
Is a daisy good?
Can't believe it's daytime only.
Now I'm stuck here.
I have like half a day.
I can't believe I wasted half.
I'm going to catch this then.
I'm going to catch these in.
Please don't take all damage.
I have a electric power.
We can...
I can give you a daisy soon.
I have one.
Oh, I put one in.
I put one in.
Okay, nice.
Whoa!
These guys hurt!
Holy shit!
How did I miss?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm just stuck here making fucking cake.
You know what?
I should just go do something else.
I'm gonna go do something else.
The spear isn't working on Dazzy levels already.
Try using a better spear.
Wait, what?
The Giga spear doesn't work on a Dazzy?
What the fuck do you need?
What?
Oh, giga, mega, ultra sphere!
Oh, there you go, there you go, I just need to damage more.
Oh, thank god, I was like, there's no way.
There's no way it doesn't work.
Come on.
Yes.
Alright, nice, some levels already.
Let's see, I can...
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna catch these tokotokos.
Okay, cool, cool.
Get over here, tokotokos.
Alright, we need to make more wheat.
Ooh.
Okay, nice.
Oh, fuck.
That is unlucky.
I'm cooking.
Why do they have to sleep at night, bro?
Are you using the Igness?
You have it.
It's not on base.
It's on base right now.
Pretty sure.
I just make it cook real quick.
Oh shit, it's hot.
Oh no, it's hot now.
No gathering.
You must make ore.
You must make ore now.
If you want pure ingots, you could teleport to the other
base I have and then just mine that.
Oh no, he's... how am I missing?
Give me that toko toko.
Yay!
not have, wait, a better workbench?
We should.
No, we do.
It's right over here.
All we do here.
Yep.
Sorry, there's cement on it right now.
Don't worry.
I'll try and work with it.
Alright.
I'll just keep cooking cake.
Rihon, where are you?
I should be able to make the...
What do we need?
What do we need in level 32 and 33?
We need to make the hot springs the better hot springs and
we need to make the just about there uh the weapon assembly
line okay i'm almost i'm like level 30 now i should get to
level 31 soon i just find a goddamn right hound wherever the
fuck they are it's daytime where are you hit him with the
summit all right
Okay.
If cement is already in the thing, then we should have
everything, I think, to build the thing.
The thing?
The hot springs?
We just need to level.
Yeah.
When we're thinging the thing?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
The thing for the thing for the hot spring?
Yeah.
Exactly.
It's so easy.
Oh, God, I can't fly.
Why is it all just a die?
I swear, these dogs are the hardest shit I've ever...
The hardest shit.
to find oh hey there's an electric egg wait oh nice this egg
could hatch it hopefully it's a gris bolt if it's a gris
then wait what what size is it has to be i haven't found a
large electric egg this is faster is it no way i'll try and
find a dog just in case i see him slower hi guys am i in the
right place chat my back seaters i am there's level 36 okay
this is awkward um okay i I did not realize they're level
36.
They're big boys.
Wow, they're...
Yeah, I mean...
This is bad.
Okay, I don't think this is faster, but...
I might die.
Just...
Uh-oh.
Rival.
Chucky might die.
Hopefully, that electric egg is just a grisble.
No, we're done.
Yeah, but if I die, we won't get the electric egg.
I'm gonna see if I can catch one, though.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try my best.
You know what?
Uh...
I'm just gonna, you know, I'm not testing this.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna bank it all on this electric egg.
Fuck this.
Actually, unless, there's one, okay, I can separate this one
guy.
I'm right, there's two.
No, you!
You're the one guy?
I'm gonna one guy, this guy.
Dang.
Make balls.
Oh my god, please, please don't run away.
This guy's level 34.
Wait, what gender do I need them to be?
I forgot.
What's the relaxatoris gender?
It doesn't matter, just get him.
No, the relaxatoris, I would need to ask, sure, I think.
I think you have one.
I have one too.
Like, I don't...
Is that male or female?
You know?
Pretty sure I only killed the live sources.
I have one as well, so...
Yeah, we need him, but...
Let me see.
It might be on the other side.
You have to throw him.
Okay, I'll try.
So, we need the Masanda, but I think we have Masanda...
We have a male Masanda, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, we only have male, then we need a female one.
Wait, sure.
him on his team put him on our team yeah but if i have him i
already have incident around on my team making the ore okay
i think it's the location wait i'm gonna try this down and
rebuild this like just much further into the farm i think
it's too far outside i'm worried you got this i'll feed you
what what the I feel like I'm going to spend the entire four
hours just making cake.
There's so many people trying to kill me.
Oh my god, please.
There's so many people involved now.
Things are going really well for Doki right now.
No, things are...
That sounds amazing.
Sounds like, man.
Oh my god, all right, I'm going to bank on...
Where's my invite?
What the fuck?
I'm going to bank on this egg.
I'm going to...
Five people just showed up to fuck me up.
Holy shit.
It literally five pals came up and just killed the two ray
hounds I had.
It was crazy Come on cake.
I just want to say noobas I'm just gonna bank on this one
egg.
I have I'm just hoping it's not a drowsy What size is the
egg large?
All right, then maybe All right, fingers crossed.
I got third party.
It's either I got third party so hard.
There he is.
Oh my god back the asynaram yeah there you fucking is all
right here i'm coming over the big boy here now all right
i'm heading over
i can you in just a second rebuild the assembly line the pal
sphere assembly line but like attempt to find i can chop
down some trees to make it more in base i think the location
oh my god he's so he's so big and broken it's fine all right
i put in i can put it in front of the beds but i think
that'll fuck things up i moved the but okay just put it here
somewhere can you just put it like anywhere in oh that's the
beds yeah we can rebuild the beds down below but they don't
seem to understand how to go down the yeah what if i put it
here it's like in between the beds as well but not so much
in front of them yeah cake all right nice time to breed do
you have any hyperspheres around um i only have giga spears
sorry i can't make hyper i was focusing on giga because i
figured i'm gonna you catch high level i'm just gonna need
giga you need giga okay i can give you some of my giga
spears you want them um you got i i can drop 15 i dropped 15
on me it's next to the berries
there's so many names where am i here thank you here's some
giga oh i'm gonna go catch some see how much yeah i'm just
gonna make some normal i'm gonna power level a little bit
wait come the back come back so i can catch the yes the new
assembly line works nice nice they're working on it now all
right cool cool all right i'm putting bushy in the breeding
oh my god please let me get down from the fucking bad worm
and i'm gonna go grab penking oh what the fuck just died
where's the assembly line go ahead it's like uh at the big
breeding time where's a stone rock thing the brick big stone
rock yeah the big stone tooth coming out of this facility oh
there it is okay i'm gonna i need
Get some normal pal balls.
Skulking around.
All right, here we go.
All right, go.
Go fall in love Make babies plop plop plop plop.
Oh, plop plop plop.
What?
Eat the cake.
I don't think make babies.
I don't think pressuring them.
How long does it take them make babies?
Oh my god I think maybe stop watching Stop watching them and
then maybe Sometimes like is that a requirement or a request
really what you say?
Really?
Do we have something to my palladium fragments?
Like the...
The Crusher.
Yeah, yeah, just...
We don't.
We should make one.
Yeah, let me make one.
Okay.
Alright, I'm just gonna construct these.
You get a spear second.
Oh, yeah, wait a minute.
For the Crusher, I wrote down this yesterday, but for the
Crusher, can we get that boss, the...
What is his name?
The little water noodle guy.
One of the bosses.
Yay!
I have an Azorob.
I have one.
Can we put him...
Can we put him out for the...
for the crusher yeah i can do it which do you want to get
rid of let me know not the miners the miners are like
essential right now uh well once bushy and what's his name
like uh stop going at it then we can put them away all right
let's just let me know and then i can put the azure rope in
there i'm just gonna i'm gonna go power level a little bit i
need because you guys i need to get to level two and level
32 and 3 for us you could also just start making some mega
spheres We just need some fragments.
We don't have enough wood for a crusher.
That cost less material.
Well, it's a good thing there's a bunch of trees around
there.
Yeah, yeah, good thing!
That's what the base is for!
I can shut down some trees often.
We gotta get to level 20!
Where the fuck are the other pals around here?
I need a power level.
It says 33 for us.
empty area I've ever seen.
That was.
Oh, there you are.
I'm going to catch a frock.
Is it enough?
I can get a bunch of magus pears.
I can probably get a power level pretty high.
We need wood for magus pears.
I'm going to have to put the elk back in here to make wood.
We need...
just need woods i mean not doing anything right now so i'm
just gonna swap her i mean just start cutting some trees
right now by yourself on it and then make some mega spheres
for sure for all right because once i get to legendary
spheres all you need is legendary spheres only cost
palladium and iron i'm pretty sure you guys need more
tombatts or They need carbon fiber.
Toma's always good, right?
I think we have an Anubis soon.
Okay, so you don't need Tombat then.
It looks like another two minutes until the first egg comes
out.
Nice.
And then, did we have...
Did we have the right genders for making the Lyleen?
I forgot.
Yeah, we do.
I got a Massandra.
All right.
I'm just...
I will need the pet, whatever, then...
Massandra's...
The Sirfoomia give her the Patalia...
Pretty soon.
Or Lyleen?
You probably got about five or six minutes.
Augie.
Get over here, Flock.
Why are none of us lucky enough for Lucky Pals?
I haven't found one yet.
Yeah, well I'm never gonna find one.
Keep that.
Sure for why aren't you lucky?
You know, my stats got rolled differently when I spawned.
Then what did you get for your stats?
I don't know, like...
Like my hands?
Your hands?
All right.
Okay.
Ah.
See you.
We just need a couple more eggs.
Deforestation sounds.
Deforestation ASMR.
Nice.
I love deforestation in game.
Deforestation ASMR.
You said that was such like a nice ASMR voice though.
I'm committed.
I'm in the role now.
Yeah, we're being immersed right now.
I'm being immersed.
Thank you very much My immersion.
Stop trying to break our immersion.
Oh my god.
My immersion.
Mom.
Oh my god.
You're embarrassing me, but I'm my friend Stop
Industrialization ASMR
Hi, all right, all right crusher is made.
Uh, do you want me to just make a bunch of palladium
fragments right now?
Yeah, because that's what's holding back the bold right now.
All right, I'm starting production.
We're going to be wiped out of rock, but that's okay.
Because I don't think we're really...
I'm on my way to make more rock.
All right, maybe the baby is born.
The baby is born!
Yes!
Clip, clip, clip.
Is it clipping time?
The baby!
It's a huge rocky egg.
Is that what Anubis comes out of?
I guess so.
Oh, wait, no, no clip.
Sorry, no clip then.
I thought you meant the baby's hatched.
No.
No clip, guys.
No clip.
False alarm.
I'm putting... False alarm.
My water broke.
Never mind.
False alarm.
I'm gonna leave them in there to make another Anubis,
though.
Okay.
Wait, just kidding.
It takes 40 fucking minutes, but we're not doing that.
Oh, no, not the dog.
Alright, then I will need Pet... Pet... Pet...
Pet... Pet... Petal...
Okay.
I'll let them make a second egg while I'm waiting for it.
What's the lowest level Anubis you can catch?
That wouldn't that shouldn't take 40 minutes if it's like a
quick, you know, like a yeah, yeah, yeah, right I hear you I
put her in the box Thank you Do I have to be level 32 or 33
for the crafting thing that you need?
uh 32 and 33.
Okay.
I'm already 32 then Okay, I'm gonna take oh, did you put did
you put her in here?
Uh, I think no, you have to put her in the base.
I can't see your box Yeah, she's in the box.
Wait, everyone has their own box?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The box.
You have to put in the...
You have to have their working.
Yeah.
Okay, so I'm just gonna get rid of this ghost bitch then.
Sounds good.
I catch an extra person for the viewing thing.
Thanks.
Because we need a view, right?
Do we know how many people we have already?
Humans?
Yeah, the humans, yeah.
We can count them real quick.
We can count them.
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Wait, start by element.
Their element is nothing, so they'll show up at the top.
I have 8.
8 of them.
Okay, I think I have, like, 5 right now.
Because we need 20 in total.
The viewing thing can be made from level 14, so it's not
hard.
Yeah, I just want to make sure we have, like, enough for...
Actually, I'll just build it.
Enough for the viewing thing.
Because we need 20, right?
Yeah.
Okay, sort.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
I have seven.
You have eight, right?
We should probably make it at the end because it'll fuck up
all of our base shit.
All right.
Yeah, I know.
I'm just wondering how much we have.
You need an azure orb, right?
Uh...
You need it?
Yes.
I wanted to use him on the base just because he's better at
water than I got azure obs in there.
Okay.
I'll grab him and I'll switch him.
Put you on the car.
crusher Like serpents all right, but Azorob should be way
faster.
Um, what do you need me to do?
I'm gonna need a power level still get some freaking stone
It's stone.
Okay.
I can grab stone now for us.
I'm getting stone.
We need more so much more more All right, I'll go mine stone
for us Can I have my buddy?
We should have enough tree tree bark for a while tree tree
tree fiber.
There we go.
Tree sustenance.
The Trinussi.
Rock and stone.
Okay, I need to make more cake.
Oh my god, all I'm doing is making cake.
That's all we need.
Bro.
Okay, there's some stone and there's some stone right now.
I quickly mined 17.
I'm gonna go power level some more.
Oh yeah, we need level 32.
Okay, what do we need in level 32?
We need more milk.
Uh, assembly line?
Did you build the hot spring?
Oh, we need the weapon assembly line.
Oh, you need the high quality hot spring or?
Yeah, high quality hot spring and the weapons assembly line.
Okay, I can milk make that now.
What do you want?
I'm gonna put this randomly.
We need, okay, we need stone for that and then where is high
quality assembly line?
Where is that?
I'm making another cake.
Nails.
We need nail, 10 more nails.
I'm gonna make 10 nails right now.
Or put it in there.
Nails.
Uh, is Ignis out here right now?
He's stuck in a tree.
Oh, I'll get him.
Silly little guy.
Silly Ignis.
Good back here.
Get someone fucking do this, and then...
I was gonna put him on my team for a second so I can control
him.
Where the fuck are the rock ones?
Um...
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Work on that.
Okay, there.
Make the gate.
go and do the rock stuff do but no do much come over here
wait I'm a genius oh my goodness wait chat watch this oh my
god what are you doing Lily where are you doing I'm gonna
farm the rock with my boar which is pretty fast and then
I'll get it all into base in one go abusing the wolf charge
oh that's big brain because then I don't care about the
weight and I have to go back and forth every time I'm
cucumbered I can't just do it in one big longer trip oh my
god you're like a gamer right now I made an improved furnace
so we can make a fine metal oh nice that's good all right
then I need to go make the coal okay cooking so hard right
now I need to make another cake though Milk, berries, flour.
Cook it!
Alright, I have a lot of stone for us.
That should be close to...
Actually, I'm close to...
100.
Too much!
Stop!
Why are you getting tired?
Keep working!
Just work, man!
Just work!
You have nothing else to do in your life!
Oh, shit, it's damage.
Alright, uh, looks like the crush...
Or they're not doing anything on it anymore, which maybe
means they're dead.
done not dead they're dead give me like 10 more minutes and
i am bringing home loads of rock they made the 61 palladium
fragments nice labor loss there's no labor loss for pals you
think there's power rights what do you think this is summer
camp no power rights there's no power rights here no power
rights if there were power rights they would not be stuck in
the fucking ball.
True.
We need two Anubis's, right?
Oh, we need cement.
We need 20 cement.
If someone can make that.
Okay.
I'm gonna get the Patilly, whatever her name is.
Get out of here.
You're so annoying.
Oh.
Do we have, how do you, how do you make cement?
Why do we need 20?
I think it has been a special workbench.
Okay, I'm gonna say we can make cement right now because we
need...
Oh no.
We need 20.
I have pal fluids too.
What level...
Where the fuck is cement?
Oh god, there it is.
It's just time to breed.
There's so many crafters.
Which one's the right one?
No, stop.
Stop being usual.
Go breed.
There you go.
Oh, it makes 10.
I didn't need 20.
Okay.
Please breed.
Thank you.
Job's done.
Yay.
Thanks.
Something need doing.
All right.
Sook, sook.
Do you think you're at your high enough level to do the hard
pals now for day two?
Year four?
What are the average levels of those guys?
They are level 40.
Nah, those guys are little 40s.
I need way more spears.
Man.
I've been on it this whole time.
Big babies.
I know, I know.
We're all struggling together.
We're trying to make as many spears as possible.
We just need a shit ton of stone.
Then a bunch of gigaspheres can start being made.
Gigaspheres.
I am bringing a bunch of spears.
What's happening to all the stones?
Wait, did you guys make some stuff just now?
With stone?
Someone must have.
Yeah, because there's like five now.
I had 80.
No, back to mining.
I go.
Let's see.
Let's hope this is a gris bowl.
Let's hope it's a gris.
Is it a gris bowl?
It is a ray hound, which is fine.
Okay, that's fine.
We got it.
It's fine.
We got what we need.
Ray hound, gris bowl.
It's the same.
All right, cool.
I yearn for the mines uh we can put more people in uh we
want somebody to do that's right okay let's see
where's my skin I need eggs too so I'm gonna spread out this
chicken should be like a lot of eggs okay I'm bringing
almost oh wait unless like you unless it expired well I had
to make a bunch of eggs so let me let me check uh oh no
sorry milk is what I need I don't need eggs Yeah, I was
gonna say I fucking brought out a ton of eggs my bad So I
didn't mean to doubt your your egg making progress or
process right I Know the best about eggs.
Don't worry about it I know everything there is about eggs
in 15 minutes time The stone base at the base doesn't seem
to get the bonus from like Makes from the hot spring now I'm
gonna put it all the way here so they have to travel down
actually boom a thousand stone all right shits are all very
dude why is there so many hungry people we need uh berries
if people have any that they've gotten on the road we don't
really do use our berry farm so this is fine i'm building
the hot spring now this is fine
what's wrong with the hot spring Why are you saying it like
that?
What's your thoughts bring?
This is fine.
Are we doing some OSHA violations over here?
It's fine.
They don't care enough.
Oh, okay.
They don't care.
It's a water slide, exactly.
It's a water slide.
Did you put it on the side of the map?
I don't know.
You get one stone.
All of this work for one stone.
Wait, unless.
Unless?
Unless.
Can I mine it with my boy?
work no way maybe you too yeah no nice okay we got the hot
spring and then we need cool weapons yeah i'm checking what
else i need for it uh oh we need a lot we need a hundred
ingots yeah i i'm i've found a student i made pal spheres in
the working i will get ingots done nice i need a hundred
ingots let me know when we've reached a hundred okay because
like that's all we need um i need milk uh flowers to be okay
i just need milk uh and then the i'll go kill the bird dash
is not really making a lot of honey which is concerning oh
i'm gonna go kill the bird dash now if someone just goes
kill and kills bees they just drop honey off true all right
it's this way oh yeah the bee is doing other oh okay well
we're okay for yeah Right now.
German tide.
Where the fuck is...
Oh wait, yes we are.
We're good.
Okay, German tide is here.
So the Verdash is like close by.
I think I'm leveled up enough for Verdash.
He's like level 34.
For sure.
Okay, it's this way.
Sure, what level are you at?
I mean, I can kill some bees right now.
Nice.
Actually, I can kill bees here.
How many, how much honey do we need?
Uh, I think actually for the amount of breeding we're gonna
do, we're actually probably gonna be okay on honey since it
doesn't expire Okay, well We can use another bee though You
can use another bee or do you want don't we need don't we
need that queen bee for something?
No, that we have the queen bee boss that we have had to kill
no, that's what I'm thinking Elizabeth bee or whatever her
name Yeah, yeah, yeah Oh god.
Oh god leave me alone leave me alone
wrong one it's my fucking thing okay yeah we need so many
more miners in the base no one is mining anything at all all
right we stream on twitch we don't really need miners in
chat i don't think i don't think we need any more miners i
think we good i think we're good um you gotta be 13 and over
to be on twitch right now i'm just saying stop tripping i'm
12 in the chat I swear to God.
13 and over.
Where is...
Where is Ash?
German Tide is here.
Oh, wait.
It's like further up.
Oh, they're...
Oh, my God.
They were so close to making the egg.
No.
They went to sleep.
That's all right.
We got...
Wait, do we need the queen bee?
Do we need the queen bee?
It's a kill.
We have to kill.
I'm also day one achievement, I think.
We have to kill and then Liza bee.
It's not a priority.
The boss or the normal boss?
Oh, okay.
I got to catch it.
Alright, because I found there's a normal Elizabeth here.
Um, we also need a little bit of milk.
Guys, do not type that you're 12.
You can actually get banned.
You will actually get banned.
Don't type that.
Don't type it.
Maybe they want to get banned.
They want to be freed.
Free them.
You will literally get banned, like, immediately.
They want to be freed from their cages.
They're cagey-wagey freeing them.
Don't do it.
Free them from their cagey-wagey.
Don't do it, bro.
Okay.
How much time we have to...
We're at the three hour mark, by the way.
Yep.
Wait.
Oh, there's three hours left.
Oh, my God.
I thought you said we've already been doing this.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, oh, my gosh.
Can you imagine?
That's all...
We only have, like, one click.
in three hours that'd be so sad i started to panic i was
like what the i've done nothing we've just been like trying
to efficient size the base and got nothing else done uh okay
for the weapons assembly line where are we at with that um
i'm just do we need more ingot we need ingots we need a
hundred ingots we have everything 184 ingots right ingots
right now yeah like that's clearly the only thing we're
missing just the ingots okay all right do we have food i'm
starving i'm on hp something's gonna sneeze on me and i'll
die just like fine just don't get invaded yeah that in that
moment we get raided right there those five berries are for
our pals okay they gotta split it between the 14 of them
well now it's too bad now they have zero oh because i'm
starving lily's life matters more than Exactly!
Oh wait, I can get some berries real quick.
I think it's done.
Starling zone has a fuck ton of berries.
I think it is done.
Sure for can make it.
Are you at the base right now?
Sure for or no?
No.
Okay, I can.
I can.
I can make it.
Um, I just, I just need to catch this, uh, catch the bird
dash and then I can come over and make it.
Whoa, get away from me.
Just a more easy, come on.
Leave me alone.
Real quick.
Where did this run?
wheat come from who's hungry mind if i roll uh oh god are
they stuck somewhere i'll grab them
come on come on daydream come on sure force daydream i think
i still own for some reason go the trade you had you had my
chickpea and i got your daydream yeah they're gonna need to
learn how to share real fast we got five berries.
Halfway.
Oh, shit.
Okay, dude, Mud, your turn.
You're level 22.
I think you'll be fine.
Actually, no.
You will not be fine.
Alright, we've got all the ingot are cooked.
Oh, shit.
What?
What the fuck did it hit me?
Okay, I was like 200 miles away and it still hit me.
Wait, how much charcoal did we need?
Let me check.
charcoal charcoal charcoal we need a hundred all right I'll
just make it right
now I need 100 of these okay wait why am I making even that
whatever it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it'll be fine
everything will be fine it's fine make baby a bubby my baby
please are we are we we have everything for the babies yet I
just need one more cake.
But the cows ain't giving me milk.
Oh no.
That's the worst part.
No.
When they're not giving the milk.
They're on strike.
You can buy the milk.
Oh shit, we're good.
We're good.
Making it.
8%.
That should be enough, right?
Cope.
oh my god why is it eight percent oh no they're all hungry
all right clip clip clip i got over a dash clip clip clip we
got we're first medium bosses let's go i'll do it manually
clip clip clip clip all right who's the next boss that is a
level 38 i am not high enough level for this shit a level 33
baby uh did anybody grab the flower i made like three of
them but nope they might be in the chest somewhere i didn't
grab anything that's okay penking all right let's see oh
never It's working.
Okay, cool.
Should help.
Just kidding.
Where the fuck is the Grudash?
I'm going to replace you now.
Alright.
Cook.
You pals need a bed now.
Do we have the ingots enough ingots to make the weapon now?
Oh, we do.
I'm going to make it.
Do you want me to place it?
Where do you want me to place it?
Literally anywhere.
Maybe down the hill.
all right i'll place it because i don't get in the way hey
i'm putting it down here putting at the edge of the barrier
i can't fucking okay here you go i can't use the boar
because i'm making i'm using him to make piles fears no boar
i am manual labor okay i'm building the assent weapon
assembly line it is done in 20 seconds Done!
Alright, I'm putting berries in, so let's stop being hungry.
37 whole berries.
There you guys go.
You don't even need to share.
Everybody gets one berry, and a little bit.
What level is the...
To cook the food?
Do we need to unlock for the electric kitchen or whatever?
Also...
41?
Sure, what level are you now?
41.
Oh.
Wait, we can make it now!
Oh, shit.
Come over here and make the pot whenever you're free.
I'll subgrade the base.
Those are two conflicting statements, you know?
By the way, we can make a third base now.
Lyleen, now I've got to make the grisbolt.
We have a improved furnace, too.
We need a large pal bed.
Nice, let's go.
All right.
What level is large pal bed?
I'm going to make grisbolt now.
We have improved ferns.
We need to make the big pal bad, by the way.
A large pal bad?
Well, surefore can make it.
That's like the level 15 one.
So we need to make high quality cloth, which we should be
able to do.
We should have enough wool.
Yeah, that's surefore's job.
This.
I'm going to...
Where's one's tower two?
I'll try and get the tower two.
Tower two.
Powered.
get the fuck back here what level is lily and lily awesome
you sit back you'll be back get the fuck back here go back
to the tent and breed what are you doing stop running golden
breeding station i think azurope is stuck assume your
station hold up i'm gonna resummon azurope she seems very
there they're not productive okay um can you please Take
care of the fucking berries so that people aren't hungry.
Thank you Stop resting go work Okay, are they breeding and
were they the oh god what are you doing?
What are you doing out here buddy?
What are you doing?
Why aren't you breeding?
Are you guys both wait a minute.
Is one of you a girl?
Nope, okay, uh wait do we have a do we have a female panda?
drug do we do we have one of those true gay wait do we have
can we get a moss moss ander who's like a lady I'm back
where do they spawn that's why the panda space is going
extinct wait what's going on we need a female moss ander we
need female why because the the wolf to make the grisbolt uh
oh wait no no no wait yeah no no i do because we're trying
to make the grisbolt oh so you need a female i need a female
okay i can get one right now we only have a kind of moscanda
do we have a male moscanda because we've only got male and
we need a wolf with it we need so we're trying to make
grisbolt i can find one right now secondary what's the
secondary right the house house and dire house ray hound the
ray hound we hatched a ray hound so yeah it's like i can
find a female i can find one right now i'm actually in the
forest right now okay cool i'm willie in the forest i'm in a
forest white now lily's in the forest what are you doing
then i'm in the forest sorry she's in the forest right now
i'm trying to find lily right now lily where are you i can
hear her i've been trying to find you for 20 years
I'm trying I'm at the Masandra forest Cool, cool, cool So I
just need to get a female I need to make more cake
Let's see Uh, milk and flour Okay Need more milk Need more
milk I just need some milk Masandra There's a lot of
Elizabeths Flying around
So many More milk, please.
Has to be my son this year.
Store it.
What do we need sure for to do it back at base again?
Uh...
Oh, we need to make the large pal bed, but I don't...
You might be able to be that...
No, I'm not.
Oh, okay.
I'm not the level.
I mean, I could get there eventually.
also we have 60 giga spheres in base okay yeah i'm gonna
collect them soon yeah level 36 we need we need to make high
quality cloth as well yeah when does that recipe unlock
that's well obviously below 480 yeah let me see if i can
make any oh we need a cooking station yeah we need sure for
it be back for cooking station so we can make the cow the
burgers and stuff yeah yeah high quality cloth is also 36 i
think like priority right now is the cooking station because
that's like two done yeah so you can come back but the
cooking station requires us to make like hold on the cooking
station is like you have to get the circuit boards to make
the cook the electric kitchen you have to be level 41 and
then you need to have uh refine ingot circuit boards well so
it's okay circuit boards is the main problem because you
can't like pure quartz you have to kind of just like get
pure course okay i yeah and that's in the the the ice area
ice bio yeah okay i can get that later okay what is wrong
with this pal i found four fucking dudes where are the
female misandras holy this is why pandas are in danger jesus
christ there's so many fucking i have no bitches there's no
bitches anywhere where did all the guys come from
Just flying around trying to find the bitches.
What do I need to build while I'm here?
Pal bed and high quality cloth if you can.
The large pal bed, both at 36, level 36.
Large pal beds and also the cloth.
Do we have the material?
Oh no, we need the high cloth.
You're the only one who can make the material and the bed.
Yeah, yeah.
We need to make two of them as well.
Do we have enough wool?
Yeah, we have way more than a lot of wool.
Yeah, we're fine with that.
well just like in your life it's so hard to find women
ah am i in the area for this now no comment maybe that's
like most sandra tinder or something just just swipe a bit
to find a female wait what are you gonna say sure for we
have a bunch of coal to make carbon fiber have we been
making coal i think we i just dropped like a hundred we have
No?
Do we need more?
You drop charcoal.
Oh charcoal, fuck.
No, I've been- I've been making- I've been doing all
breeding.
Um, I should fly out and just get that started though.
Oh, we don't have coal at all?
Oh shit.
That's how we did.
Once I make- Once I make this cake, I will go down there.
And start making it.
I'll go make the base for coal.
I guess I don't care if I get hit.
Uh, I need to make a tropical outfit.
Oh shit.
I've basically become a glorified pal.
Because all you're doing is working.
Because the pal's hour and a half, I'm just like, yeah, I'm
mining and chopping trees and working the pals for your
bench.
My favorite pal.
Lily.
That's my favorite pal.
Don't worry, that's how some people are on other teams too.
You're not the only one.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure about four people in each team is
like, Well, one of them at least is banished to pile the
wood.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Since we don't have the Mossandra, I'm gonna fly out and
start making the coal base.
Yeah, yeah, just go make that.
Finally!
I'm just gonna keep trying to find a fucking Massandra.
What a type of hands!
Oh shit, Van Worm, you're fucking dying.
Oh well.
Van Worm...
Better than Van Worm, they've got the...
What is it called?
The beacon?
I'm level 34!
34 okay that sucks where the fuck are you oh i see are the
gorillas i'm gonna leave ignis here and take back this
fucking panda and let me grab
my worm there has to be a female somewhere all right uh you
should suggested the place by the anubis um let me just take
a look at my thing no don't shoot him please oh the first
one is where I built my base but this I found one you're the
anubis is the base one yes oh yeah you anyone the anubis is
technically in like a less dangerous location it's only got
six nodes they said that there's a place in the deep sand
dunes that has eight nodes of coal but I first picture I
linked is a place where there's a waypoint and you can fly
to the top left mountain and you don't even need to make a
base.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's convenient.
All right.
I'm just gonna try to get over there then.
Because I don't have any waypoints out that way yet.
Yeah, just just head there.
Negative 125, negative 84, negative 125, 125, 84.
Okay.
All right, nice.
Okay, I got the...
Oh!
All right, I got the female.
I'm just gonna put it in base whenever you're ready to breed
it.
I don't...
I'm just gonna...
Actually, I can breed it for us.
Yeah, I'll do the breeding for us.
Yeah, yeah, put it in the...
I've got the wolf.
I'll put the wolf out.
I did it.
I got the female.
Now I can...
Okay, I got the wolf.
Give me a second.
all right
thank you i'm just getting heading to the waypoint and then
i'll pass over pass it over is that all we need for greeting
or do we need anything else nope that's all we need there's
cake in there already um we just need them to make a
grisbolt all right
At the two-hour mark, we should do the dungeons.
Okay.
Sounds good.
Alright, I gotta go...
I gotta leave base for it and go make the other base.
Alright, I'm just going to put...
Is there...
Actually, you can...
You can do the breeding right now since you're here.
I'm here.
Okay.
Alright, cool.
What do we get rid of?
You can get rid of...
I'll just move this guy out for right now.
There you go.
Open spot.
all right i'm gonna go do the second tower no come back no
come here where are you going where are you going second
tower come back okay i got him this faction tower faction
tower to location let's go let's go breed it is time for you
to breed powered
where the fuck is the second tower can't be assigned what do
you mean can't be assigned yes you what do you mean yes
again sometimes the hitbox seems to creep over other shit
the what hitbox the the like when you try to assign the pal
sometimes yeah seems to overlap with other shit oh that's
i'm just what the does that mean hold on wait a minute can't
be assigned that's weird with breeding where you have to
take out you have to like put two females in and to like
make it unbug i don't know the bugs are annoying yeah that
sounds It's really annoying.
It says it's not compatible with cooling.
Wait, what?
What?
I don't, what the fuck does that mean?
What does that mean?
Are you- What the fuck does that mean?
There's three misandras in front of me.
I fucking- That's crazy.
Okay.
I literally found just found more misandras.
Okay, I- Now it says nobody's at the breeding ground.
okay just take them out and put it back in yeah i'm taking
them out and that should fix it i sign you to a tree i sign
you to literally whatever just get out of there okay okay
wait more stone again go lily go lily pal just it keeps
saying i can't put the most the the panda in there because
of instability with cooling.
Just try and put, like, two females in there.
I'll put two.
I'll try to.
That one is a female, though.
Just unbug it.
Just unbug it and then see what happens.
Yeah, the panda is a female, though.
So it should be able to... Okay.
If it saves that cooling, it usually means that they're on
break and they need to wander around for a bit.
That's what some of my chat says.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
They're too mad to Yeah, they need a break.
Can I like force them to sit in the olden?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
All of us supposed to be natural.
Consent is sexy.
I said to go on a spa date.
I said go on a spa date.
I didn't say I didn't say that.
I don't know if you're a right fit for this team now.
What the heck?
After all I've done for this team?
HR needs to speak to you real quick after that.
When did we hire HR?
Oh, ever since you talk about consent.
Man, not again.
All right, I'm gonna see if I can fucking do this boss
battle.
I can put her in here now.
So that's like, that's a good sign maybe.
Wait, I want to take my cake.
bad all right i don't know if i'm high enough level for this
but we'll see yeah back to stone we don't have a choice that
trust the process chad just just trust the process trust the
pal trust lily she is a certified pal best pal i've been
accepted into the pal world look i'm one of them i can't
even tell the difference i don't know if i'm like high
enough level for
all right maybe now they don't need a break we go and find
out 67 that okay wait maybe oh my god i'm fighting lily i'm
fighting lily right now yo beat them the fuck up yeah i'm
gonna beat the shit up
So I need to talk to HR, but that's fine.
Look, I've been...
Look, you're too new here to do that, you know?
You don't know if that'll yet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're too new here right now.
You have to be more established to be able to beat up Lily.
All right, it looks like it unbugs.
Oh, hell yeah, they're in love.
Whoops, wait, no, I'm not trying to cut you right now.
Please let me Orion deal with the egg.
Just kidding.
I think I just put both of the...
Wait, yes, hell yeah.
Yeah, all right, cool.
They're making a baby.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
While they do that, I'm gonna go make the coal base.
Whoa.
Please.
Please leave me alone.
Oh, no.
All right.
Oh, no, I'm poisoned.
I need some food for myself, and then I can go, can I make
another cake?
I should know if I can kill this in time.
We need egg.
Oh, no, we didn't fucking what?
We need so much stuff.
It's never done!
It's never over.
Now I know what they feel like.
Now you know why they have zero rights.
Now you know.
And they'll never get rights.
This is terrible.
This is capitalism.
Welcome to capitalism.
Enjoy your state.
Plus you have no other choice.
I enjoyed my state.
I enjoyed my time.
Yeah, of course you did.
Oh my god.
I don't think I can kill the second tower, girl.
She's way too strong.
She wicked.
My fucking pals are too fucking weak.
She's like, oh no, she's too strong.
Oh god, sweeper, please, sweep, sweep.
She's like, oh no, she'll beat me up.
Oh no, she's gonna beat me up.
That's awful.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
I would hate to know where that tower is, where this girl's
beating you up.
That would be...
I just want to know so I can avoid it.
That sounds terrible, you know?
Like, oh my goodness.
Come on, sweeper.
You're so tanky.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
I'm at 40,000 out of 70.
We're slowly getting there.
All right, cool, cool, cool.
All right.
I'm so close.
Go, Pen King.
You're our last hope.
Do we have the other, the Anubis yet?
Uh, they're both hatching.
They're still not hatched?
No, they take 40 minutes each.
Jesus Christ, they're so fucking tanky.
I know, that's why I've been stuck at the base.
I've just been doing breeding.
Wait, is the Anubis the longest one to breed?
or is it a large axe or all the same hour at 45 we've got
one more minute left on the first noobus egg uh which is
good because then i can put in the next egg so which is the
we need to make sure we have enough to time to breed the
other ones too i think we're gonna be like giddy giddy okay
it just depends on well we can make a we can make a third
incubator uh we need one for the gris that i'm trying to
hatch okay i can make it the moment i fucking beat up this
lily okay What do I do?
Why are you so tanky, Lily?
Just die already!
It makes me a very hard-to-work-for-the-team.
Lily, I need these points, Lily!
Do-for-the-team, Lily!
Can't even get the proper beating here.
What the fuck, man?
Oh my gosh, these are the work conditions I have to live
with.
All
right, wait, we gotta...
We're gonna we're gonna check it you guys ready?
You ready to clip Three two one incubation complete.
I'm pulling out the huge rocky egg if it's not anubus.
I Hey clip clip clip clip clip clip clip clip clip clip clip
clip clip clip clip clip clip clip clip clip clip all right
Oh, shit This is the last tree that I chopped Jesus Christ
That should last us a good 10 minutes.
Because the bag's like, I need more.
I really need eggs.
Did I say you killed Verdash already?
Yeah, I killed Verdash already.
Verdash is the only thing I killed.
Or like captured.
Verdash is the only one I captured.
Gosh.
Hell yeah.
Okay, cool.
Alright, I'm leaving that cake.
I'm gonna grab the egg and then I need to go do coal.
Shit.
Stay tuned.
Please have baby.
Okay, they're gonna go to sleep.
Yeah, fuck that.
I'm gonna go.
Come on, Van Worm.
Do we have the crusher to make fragments?
Yeah, we have the crusher already being used.
Oh my god, 20k.
Come on, 20k is 4 minutes, please.
What the heck is it?
Not to lie.
Is this a crusher?
All right, pals, I respect that you need food, but I also
need food, so We're always gonna just take some of that Oh,
shit I back to rock Back to rock, you go Back to being a pal
I love being a pal Go, go, go All right, fly now Please Why
Are you so tanky?
Wait, do I need tropical clothes?
Probably need tropical clothes.
Tundra outfit, no.
Back to rock.
I need my tropical clothes.
Oh, how much rock have you farmed in total?
I'm actually curious, Lily.
Oh my goodness, like, I won't pay good money to have to have
someone go back and count all of what I find.
Everything you farm.
Just accumulate everything.
Oh no!
Just so I can feel accomplished.
My bad work died because I wanted to know how you're doing!
Well, we got the Anubis now.
We got the Anubis now and he's like flying through rock.
Nice.
That's good.
So...
That should help a little.
Oh no, I can't even aim anymore.
What the fuck is going on?
No.
No!
Who's that?
Better pals for mining?
I don't know.
I'm level 24.
options i was saying you're new to keep me oh no i'm not new
i'm almost killed i almost killed her i have two minutes
left to kill it sleeper why are you hungry he's like mother
i crave substance don't have time for you to be hungry right
now oh god oh man i'm basically a farming pile wait can i
just take a and manually farm with him is that gonna be
faster than a rush I have no idea maybe I feel like this is
the fastest and I know it was in the fastest clip clip clip
clip oh my god we did it okay my entire team is hungry oh my
god if I named him he would be called yeast infection what
excuse me it's just a little fun name I came up with so fun
I don't know we can name him like UTI or something what is
going on of your life right now is everything okay i think
so yeah why are people worried i'm a little worried i mean i
wasn't 30 seconds ago but i will admit come on you're
convinced now like it's a fitting name all right let's see
oh i oh wait now i self-boot nice yeah man i'm so upset my
parents didn't name me uti i could have been my life you
could have had it all i think vtubers exist i need like nine
i'm gonna try and find line right where the fuck is the
crusher you wanted to be called samsung galaxy man
i need it i'm trying to find the where's the crusher is at
the bottom uh crusher is in the corner close to the cliff
back yeah by the by the large cliff which is a large cliff
i'm going to try and find the crusher uh where the oh there
it is okay nice all right i can make another incubator nice
maybe you guys need it okay uh also the the i had to leave
before they finished breeding because it's nighttime but if
you're there in the daytime can you grab the egg um and uh
we need another incubator wait what eggs what is there not
any eggs right now that can be put in incubator they're
they're really close to giving birth but they went to sleep
okay so no wait no there's an egg here there's already an
egg here oh sweet all right can you pop that in the make
another incubator if possible and pop that in there okay a
huge electric egg i'm putting not in yeah that's gonna be
griz all right here we go and then we just have to hope that
it's the right gender otherwise we got to get another
relaxesaurus too all right i mean relaxesaurus is easy to
catch so i'm finding that all right let's see how much time
seven minutes till okay i'm trying to look at what we need
right now um sure for what are you doing right now sure for
I'm doing stuff.
Oh, it's high quality cloth.
I don't have to cry.
It's not that bad.
It's okay.
It doesn't have to be first place.
I'm getting along.
What are you doing?
What are you doing right now?
Sure, boy.
I was trying to see if the high quality cloth was finished
making, but it's not.
Now I'm waiting for daytime and I'm leveling.
You're leveling?
What level are you right now?
I'm 44.
44?
Oh, all right.
Actually, that's the max we need for the base.
so let's see i'm trying to see what how many hours do we
have left we're 23 minutes till the two hour mark so we need
to see trying to see max amount paladin i'm trying to see
what i have to do right now of rock i shall be able to try
and catch some of the day one i'm gonna do some of the day
one bosses then um just to faster level up and because for
the higher level bosses I need ultraspheres, I think.
Oh, wait, what am I doing?
Okay.
Would you, uh, let's see.
I'm going to go do the day one stuff so I can level up to at
least level 40.
And then...
Okay, you didn't get the bronze cherry, right?
I don't remember which ones we...
Have we done Nightwing?
Oh, there's a list somewhere in the Discord.
My mods...
Actually, my mods might be able to post again, but they have
a picture of all the stuff we did on day one.
yeah can you show me like what we were missing in day can pp
mod show me what we're missing day one for the bosses thank
you so then i can like breeze through it real quick for us
um i know like the bronze cherry we have mvpps all right let
me look you're my mvpps thank you the global uh global
events whatever the most points anyways did we get the
fenlobe have we done the fenlobe yet bird okay i'm gonna get
the uni vault then you haven't done the uni vault yet right
i don't think so all right i'll get that uh the uni vault is
40 20 points look at that's 20 points that we can get
oh wait i need to get my forgot to grab my fucking van worm
van worm are you done healing yourself
minutes.
Alright, I guess I'll stay here and help out with the wood.
Do we need wood or rock?
More.
Let me see.
Rock.
How's Anubis pulling?
He's doing amazing.
Let's go!
Let's get some rock for us then.
While we I'll get some rocks.
I don't have enough.
I don't have my van worm to grease through.
Actually, I'll just fucking ride the dog.
I don't want to waste time.
all right the dog over oh shit it's broken uh oh crap baby
do mud right now
oh please don't fall van worm i know you can make it to this
someone can hatch the other nannubis right now the other
nannubis can be hatched i'm not i'm not at the base yet so
lily you should patch it all right let's go chad says he is
but i'm mining as well go make him work the moment he's born
that's his moment he's born hello baby anyway into the mines
you go baby you're in for the mines you guys are laughing
but that's what they did with children on farms that's true
Into the mines, you gold.
Soon as soon as you're 12, you're going to be working on the
farm.
As God intended.
Perfect for the mines.
Alright.
Look, if God didn't want them to work in the mines, then
kids should not exist.
You sure?
I'm 100% sure.
Oh, I think I went past where I was supposed to go.
Wait, no, I didn't.
Yes, and my parents should have put me in the mines.
Born to roam free, forced to mine.
You're seeing it as if it's a bad thing.
Also, if we have the eggs, we also need to make one more
cake.
If anybody's on base and can make a cake.
I can probably queue one up if we have.
Yeah, I'm just...
Wait, we have a...
Okay, there's a...
Oh, I'm going to relax the stories.
You guys can catch it.
Relax the stories.
Catch some.
Catch some because then if we don't have the right gender,
it won't matter.
Yeah, yeah.
Somebody...
I ain't there.
Lily's there.
Lily is your job.
Lily, it's time.
It's time, Lily.
I kept the balls in order.
I kept the balls away.
There's more balls in the base.
I'm dead.
Wait, you're dead?
I can't do it.
I'm fucking dead.
I just one shot me!
What?
I fell through the map!
Let me go!
What happened?
Donkey, they've got the list in Discord, by the way.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Under the sea!
Okay.
She's swimming, but she did.
I have a Univolt if we need it later.
To the shadow realm!
Wild but only good You sure about that yes
Mine back to work Work work work work work It's time to get
back to work work work work Ow Sweep sweep sweep sweep sweep
sweep sweep sweep sweep He's sweeping That was fun.
Let's have some more of some time.
Okay, you really do sound like the voice from the game
though.
You can fess up.
You can just tell me that you're the guy from...
That, you know...
See, I would be a sick voice actor.
We have 88 voice.
Get a voice reel right now.
And apply.
I don't know how that fucking works.
Don't I have to join like some voice actors guild or some
shit?
No, I don't think so.
I think...
Use your clout.
I'm a voice actor.
Done.
It's that easy.
It's just that easy.
If you never try, if you never try, you'll never get
employed.
I don't want to try.
Why not?
I just want everything to be given to me.
I got a protocol.
Spoken like a true content creator.
I just need to make sure he doesn't and fucking die.
Alright.
Come on.
18%.
Clip, clip, clip.
Got the Univolt.
Clip, clip.
I think I'm pretty close to where I need to be.
I got a Univolt.
Nice.
How to become a voice actor.
Step one.
Declare intent.
It's just that easy.
Amazing.
I am voice actor.
hire me done please accept me I'm so happy for you dude you
really worked hard at this this is my follower count I'm
pretty sure we have enough dragon types do the dragon
petting thing I think we have enough water too I'm pretty
sure I think like we should start petting at an hour mark I
think at two hour mark we should do dungeons
I met somebody's dead stuff location.
Trevor, are you high enough level for the...
Oh, wait.
You might be at my dead stuff.
For the...
You are, that's my dead stuff.
Can you pick it up?
Oh, you're in my guild, so yeah, probably.
I don't know if there's anything useful in there.
I've recovered ever since, but you can...
I need better balls as a thing.
I'm trying to look for a waypoint.
A dive of, like, pretty much nothing.
What do we need for hyperspeers?
Do you guys know?
Oh, yeah, I took it all.
Trevor, what mats do you need for hyperspeers?
Let me see.
I'm looking for...
Cement.
How do I make cement?
Six coal, one stone.
Six coal, one ore.
Okay, okay.
What mats do we need for Hyper Spear Share for?
I got it covered, but I can't queue a mob.
I will just make sure we have the materials.
There's no fast travel over here.
Wait, what?
Also, your mods said they made a list.
but where is it?
Uh...
There's no list in here.
I can just copy paste it.
Hold on.
I think they didn't even post it.
No, I think they...
Wait, here.
There you go.
I think they posted it in the wrong chat.
Okay.
All right.
I need...
Chill it.
Do we not do chill it?
Or did we do chill it?
Oh, those are the ones we did.
Can you give me a list of those we need to do?
Because that's easier for me.
Oh, what we need to do.
For day one, bosses.
Because that's easier for me to keep track.
um i'm gonna capture two black marketeers through us now
since that's something i can do all right let me take a look
at the dm i'm gonna set the base now uh on the coal spot
once i get a shotgun some twilight dunes okay i can meet the
boss well i have um twilight dunes is on this 88 gigaspheres
i can't make hyper yeah yeah i'm gonna once i get the
refined metal i'll make the hyper how do you get refined
metal again We need coal.
We need coal.
We still need coal.
I'm about to mine so I'm gonna circle.
I'm gonna put away...
Okay, back to stone.
Nice.
I've used up all the stone.
Black marketeers are tough.
Well, I have to do it for the team.
Bad worm.
No, I'm starving.
I don't know, whoever told me it's easier to manually mine.
of anubis i feel like you're you're i feel like my bore was
more effective maybe you're not doing it right get all of
these stones okay hold up wait let me put him into the base
because i feel like he's more useful in here to do the stone
mining in here for now while i'll get my manual stone wait
that's not that's not cool Um, they don't need this, so I'm
gonna eat it.
Oh, no, stop being hungry.
Isn't he a low level?
That shouldn't matter for mining.
It's not fighting a pal.
It's just mining.
Uh...
God, I'm a boar.
Where is one of the black marketeers?
Let's see.
141...
41-404?
It's supposed to be right here.
Hold on.
I'm trying to like figure out where the black marketeers
are.
There's one right below our base.
Yeah, I'm trying to...
Oh, it's this thing right here.
It's this thing right here.
Okay.
I got it.
I see it.
I found the spot.
Is this it?
Is this the marker for that?
I think so.
All right, I'm gonna see if I can catch him.
Oh!
No, that's not you.
all right i don't know what level they are what level are
they the the one underneath is 40 okay the rest are like 50
i think i'm 36 i think that'll be fine i'm 36 it's fine it
shouldn't be that bad right oh yeah well that toko toko is
good yeah yeah yeah it should be where am i i'm walking
around he always fly the wrong way
Coal can't be assigned.
What?
I need some wood.
I need hyperspeers to catch the marketeers.
Does the gigaspere not work?
I'm getting somewhere.
It might just be a really, really, really, really low
chance.
You know, I'm going to risk it.
I'm going to risk it.
It'll be fine.
I have enough gigaspers to fucking risk the catch.
Wait, what the fuck?
I have a grenade?
Throwing Garnata.
Nice.
I tried to go to punch and then a grenade came out.
And I was like, ugh.
Alright, back to you.
Oh god, I'm so stupid.
Oh wait, cause it's not my axe.
It's Lily's axe.
That's where this axe came from.
Hello.
Oh yeah, you got her stuff?
Thanks for the axe.
Yeah, I got your stuff.
You're welcome, you're welcome.
Alright, here we go.
It's time to risk this.
We'll be fine
All right, Cole I put a pal box out here now.
We've got a fast travel.
What the fuck?
Okay Go to your thing.
I was told we need wood.
I'll get wood.
Oh, he has a pal too Yeah, and a machine gun.
Oh my god, my pal's almost dead.
All right.
I stopped risking it You know, sure for this is your job.
I'm not doing this Shit.
This one too.
Alright.
He is way too strong.
Who's good at mining that I've got in my party right now?
Wait, can they not mine the coal?
I can come mine the coal.
They should be able to.
I put Tombat out here, but Tombat's not doing anything.
I need more nails for the large power bed.
Do we need more nails?
Okay.
We need more for that, right?
Just iron.
I know we need ingots.
Ingots, okay.
You can queue up some ingots.
I held off because I wasn't sure how much we need for like
the refined.
They can mine coal, but you have to take away the mining
station.
What?
No, you need level three for coal.
You need level three pals.
Mining.
That's what they said.
Okay, okay.
Who can we get that's level three?
I'll just... Is Anubis?
Anubis is, but I want to try something.
Okay, I'm gonna need one of the Anubis This is here to start
getting cold.
Where can I make Palmer?
Okay, where is your PPM?
Found you.
You can see it on the map.
You'll need tropical clothes to come out here though.
You need Palmer?
Sure for it?
But I have your stuff, so if you had tropical clothes,
then...
I did not have that.
It's time for Google.
I'll just very quickly try something and see if that works.
I have chat.
That's fine.
You have chat.
I can indeed mine coal.
So if you can make me close, I can already get started.
Okay, I'll make you that.
all right i can mine this super fast okay put that out pp
mud pp mud you information is not correct you're in for wait
actually wait univolt yeah we capture univolt yeah what do
you mean you don't see a clip i said clip clip clip okay
your mod your mod fucking missed the univolt here shy lily
i'm just gonna give you mine okay okay can you bring it to
me i'm yeah i'm just gonna drop this i'm gonna like drop it
on the ground oh god is everything okay there come on you
can do it i'm cute you can do it okay i'm gonna fly back and
i'll come back and make some stuff what do we need here i'll
finish the coal and i'll return to base and then i'll do
rock okay okay i'm gonna go back gonna make uh another trap
vault fit um sweet can you guys link the the the clip of me
catching uni vault for the mod oh nigga guy all right how's
it going with the breeding uh well i'm not there i'm fucking
doing bosses okay all right i'm taking a look okay all right
this is here uh all right so this one going we've got a griz
that's set to hatch uh so i think we're good see i'm getting
the linaris for us or the 12th place right now but we also
have like not been getting doing a lot of points trust the
process give me your meat i my pal team's hungry all right
uh now that they bred we don't actually need need this one
out anymore i can't believe sure for and i have not found a
single lucky pal i'm not lucky i've established this state
yeah but i haven't either i've not heard a single shiny
it's actually crazy we haven't heard anything all right i'm
gonna take one of the anubuses we've got two anubus right
yeah wait uh lily do you think i should bring one of the
anubuses out there or no just let them do the stone because
we are also low on stone like chronically always and i'll be
getting this cool done before respawns all right yeah if we
had time it'd be great if we could make a second like
another anubis but we just there's no way there's no way it
takes like 40 minutes minimum yeah because you can make
anubis like breed with anubis and we have a female and male
anubis but just it's not gonna happen i don't think you guys
have time for the breeding and Absolutely not.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
I am basically an Anubis.
True.
You're basically the pal.
Anubis at home.
Wait, sure.
Can you make the large pal beds?
We don't have the nails yet.
The cloth.
Oh, we don't have nails?
Are we low on nails?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll do that.
We should have lots of ore that we can make until ingots.
touch the ingots yet because i'm pretty sure we need higher
quality stuff so i can yeah we need to make that's what
we're getting the cold for that's what the colds were all
right come
on fan worm come on okay nice should be it oh shit i'm so
fucked up right now bro i'm so fucked up i'm so fucked up at
the moment i almost Fucked up right now.
Oh my god.
I have that one hit.
That's my world is so intense I still have to like four I am
supposed to play a power world you guys.
Oh, I'm actually almost dead guys Oh, no, oh, I just touched
it even though it was lagging Bro gamer bro gamer.
Oh, it's lagging so hard Okay, I'm good Okay, clip clip clip
clip clip clip clip clip I don't know how to say it again!
Clip, clip, clip!
Thank God, Linaris.
Holy shit.
I was like one HP.
Not even close, baby.
Wait.
Why am I doing this?
You should be.
Come here, you big guy.
What are you even doing?
What are you doing?
Come here.
Okay, he's stuck.
grab him.
Oh, no, I'm too far.
Nice refined ingot.
Let's go.
Close now.
Ah.
All right.
Damn it, please.
I'm busy.
Yes, please.
Damn it, please.
Fuck off.
I'm busy.
Oh, my goodness.
Doesn't Anubis walking around.
Oh, wait.
That's a boss.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get away from that Nubis.
Don't get close to that one oh my god another anubis another
anubis what the heck you guys
oh my god like i'm not even lying right now but i just saw
an anubis oops i pressed the wrong button we're going to
skate park i didn't want to go to skate park okay oh my god
where the fuck is and you i'm trying to find like a waypoint
so i can come home uh let me bring some stuff to you how are
we doing how many coal have you already gotten i have mined
all the coal i'm picking it up and i'll let you know how
much it is i'm gonna start looking for the dungeons now so
we can get the dungeons done okay we had the brown cherry
there's there's actually a couple areas with um with the
coal ore in that area if you actually just want to like go
and mine the rest of them that would actually be super duper
freaking helpful let me send you the map's already in the
discord but i'll grab it again okay i have 800 coal okay oh
800 coal that's a lot of coal i told you i'm i'm a pile yeah
we don't you guys don't need no we need more coal for for
sure for his like gun stuff don't we okay yeah yeah i need
too much coal for that holy shit That was what I was most
worried about.
Yeah, that's why Lily's our best pal.
Don't worry, I'm her best pal.
Best pal, Lily!
Best pal.
She's our level 50 pal right there.
Right there.
Do I count?
Can you, like, sign me up for achievement?
Level 50 pal.
Level 500 points right there.
That you can't.
There's not actually a good part, but, like, you know.
All right, we need quartz.
All right, then what should I do right now?
This egg's gonna hatch and next I need to make the orcirk.
So once we have gris bolt hatched how long till gris hatches
Gris is in five Yeah, but we'll be able to clip in 20
seconds clip clip clip I got brown cherry clip clip clip
Brown cherries done.
Okay, we need to start making a bunch of refined ingot like
basically we just have to make like a fuck ton of refining
it how do we make refining it refining it i'll take care of
that yeah that's that's like the number one thing that we
need we need how many refining it's we need like hundreds
okay i can start with 87 for now and then i'll go back to
all right lily was born clip clip clip clip clip clip oh
lily's yay i've been we've been we we got another lily let's
go we can't replace it All right, we're going to swap out
this inferior Leah with this superior Lily.
Oh, my God, we can finally replace her.
You, your position has become redundant.
Now it doesn't matter if you get sick.
You have become useless.
No worth.
For your services.
Thank you.
You don't get a pension after.
Rest in peace.
We need milk and egg, but it doesn't really fucking matter,
so it's all good.
All right, next thing we need to breed.
First off, why have you just been in here doing nothing?
We have enough time to breed the rest, or...
Yeah, yeah, we're good.
We're gonna be good.
Because we still have to do the other stuff, so...
I'm just a little worried.
Yeah, no, we're gonna be good.
The last thing we need to breed is pretty much once his
Grisbolt is done in four minutes.
If we have the correct sex, then I can immediately breed the
last one.
If we don't...
Then I'm gonna need somebody to get another relaxesaurus.
I have.
I'll show you.
I'll see what relaxesaurus I have.
Um, but I'm gonna maybe go try to get pure crystals, maybe.
Um, I have a male relaxesaurus right now on me.
Maybe you guys need a male.
This is a female.
Otherwise...
Let's see.
I need to fucking replace some of my pals in here.
Uh, Univore, Lunaris.
I do not need.
I need 40 nails.
Nice.
Don't do it.
Let me see where they're at.
We're at 26 nails.
I'll help.
I think I can do another...
I can do a...
I killed a Mammarist, right?
Yeah, I can.
Let's see.
Where is the Mammarist?
Is the Mammarist the one in the beginning?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, let's see if I can kill it.
Let's see if I can kill this.
If you need help, good luck.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
appreciate that if you need to help no one can good luck
yeah no one can help you but if you need on your own goodbye
all right let's see go van worm go hey it's all right all
right nails are done okay put him in the box it's fine uh
apparently it's not are they in a box i'm about to put in my
box yeah okay i the box was full okay they're in the box now
I just gotta put this somewhere.
Oop.
Oh, this boss is easy.
I'm so fucking tanky now.
Or my pals are tanky.
Go, pal.
Go.
Oh.
I'm so good at Dark Souls now.
I'm so good at Dark Souls.
Two minutes on that one.
Alright, we need to make circuit boards.
So I'm just gonna go get some pure quartz.
Yeah.
Chat, do you know if there's like any particularly rare?
really good spot for pure quartz or is it literally just
wander around the mountain i know there's that lake the
unthawable lake has a lot of them uh all right i'll head to
the lake we'll see please please you need well why are you
so weak okay uh and then we okay two pal beds i'll help i'll
help build be alone me alone oh my god please you built two
of them right yeah sure did you did you build two of these
pal beds yeah okay cool you can upgrade it now other one
it's like to the right of it okay or the left of it you
should be able to level up the base now right yeah yeah once
these two are built we'll be able to level up the base what
level is our base now uh it's gonna be 16 or 17 the next one
pretty much all comes together by finishing the electric
furnace once the electric furnace is done uh we're gonna
we're pretty much gonna skip level three level 17 and 18 and
we're just gonna do the build for 19 because the build for
19 will speed up how long it'll take for us to 17 and 18 i
like did the math last night and it's just better to just do
the 19 base uh objective first all right come on all right
base upgrade done all right refined metal chest Nice.
Come on, Mammarous.
All right, let me check.
Refined metal chest.
Okay, we need a refined ingot nail wood.
Okay, can you build us the refined metal chest?
What level is it?
It is level 39.
Yeah.
Okay.
That should be fine.
The next thing we're going to need, we're going to need a
bunch of circuit boards.
refined ingot so I'm gonna go I'm gonna get the grisbolt
situation figured out first but then I'm gonna go try to
farm the quartz I'm just trying to catch my mammal why is it
5% holy
shit this mammal rest is taking fucking forever well it's
not a mammar active it's a mammarast that's why it takes so
long Jesus Christ I'm still left.
Oh my god.
I think I definitely need a hypersphere some shit How where
the mats for hypersphere?
I have we have all the mats.
I just can't kill them.
Oh, okay.
Circuit ports have filled the sphere assembly line.
So Mamma rest is caught.
Clip clip clip clip.
I got it.
I feed your pal.
Oh my god.
Never mind Clip clip clip clip clip.
All right, cool.
No I'm going to try and find dungeons for us now because we
production assembly line.
We need to do dungeons at the two hour mark and we're at the
two hour mark.
So I'm going to try to find the dungeons and you guys do
your thing.
All our eggs are incubated.
I'm going to hatch them.
We can make a third base, by the way, so we can teleport
everybody to the dungeons.
We got Grisbolt.
Do we need a Grisbolt?
Let's go!
The Grisbolt and we got, I'm hatching the scorching one.
What is the gender of the Grisbolt?
I'm going to check now.
Grisbolt is Female.
And we have a male Relaxasaurus.
Let's go!
Who do we get?
Who are we replacing?
Can you take out the ones I'm replacing?
They're all sleeping, so it doesn't matter.
Yeah, but I'll just take out.
I'll take this guy out.
Okay, Relaxasaurus is here.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, cool.
No, no, don't sleep.
No.
Get up.
Okay, I just got to wait till they land.
I can't put them in there.
I'm trying to look at what the dungeons are caverns of doom
dungeon okay i know you put that for dungeons caverns of
dune okay it's in the desert okay it's level it's level 38
dungeon which is fine sure 4 and i are high enough level hey
all right breeding is gonna be fine we're we're good nice
yeah i just need to get the circuit board so i can make the
spheres so i can get the hyperspheres so then i can oh yeah
start catching the bosses i'm gonna get the materials for a
basis so you guys can teleport to me to do the dungeon okay
sounds good okay we have i can make then you can also start
teleporting us to those islands so yeah yeah so how much
refined ingot do we need i have 87 and i can make 330 it'll
be a hundred it'll be a hundred refined ingots to make the
uh sphere assembly line And then for the balls, it's...
So I'll just max it out so you can queue up all the balls,
maybe.
Five per ball.
Okay.
We just queue up all the units.
The major problem with the production assembly line is just
circuit boards.
It's probably better if...
Can I make polymer yet?
I make pal metal ingots, and then I make legendary spheres.
I just need cement and carbon fiber.
All right.
We also need to make polymers.
i'm not level 33 so i need to get up a couple levels before
i can do that so if we can make a bunch of cement that would
be i can we have any i can make like a lot more 200 more am
i in the right area if i can just make legendary spheres
then it'll be way easier to catch the i'm gonna start
reading to make a rock all right you guys do that i'm just
gonna find us that fucking dungeon where the heck let's take
him down wait no not you we have no more anubis in the base
wait we have one anubis we should have I took one of the
anubis just to start making some I'm gonna put them back
okay yeah no it is this guy and Griswold okay last breed oh
where the fuck is a dungeon okay I am looking at and then
grab back to rock trying to find the dungeon spawns on the
on the little guide you made
i hope it was helpful i i like got really uh like i started
looking into all the stuff i needed for breeding and then it
just led me down a rabbit hole of all the other things i
needed no that's not it oh the dungeons right breeding time
breed breed breed wrong mouth it's so hard there they go
there they go fall in love I'll leave you to it good luck
just fall in love it's that easy just do it good luck with
the fertilization you're like all you need is a cake and
then they'll fall in love that's all no no it's not falling
down Well, I hope it's not exhibitionism because I don't
want to stand up.
Okay, at the one hour mark, we start petting.
Yes, yeah, we start...
Okay.
We start petting together.
I don't know why that makes me laugh every time you say it.
I'm just like, okay.
We just do group petting.
What's so funny about that?
Yeah, what's so funny?
This is a serious thing.
Yeah, yeah, you're right.
You're right.
Sorry.
I had the giggles, my bad.
Oh my god.
How dare you laugh about petting?
Right.
They're like group petals.
yes my favorite pal world hobby group petting of course
people need a pet too yeah yeah you're so right you're so
right what the hell are you guys talking about can i be
padded since i've been doing pal work i feel like i deserve
with this statement.
You calm down.
I was just like, please.
Please shut the fuck up, please.
You're just sitting there like, oh my God, please stop
talking.
I'm the only male here.
I don't want, I'm on.
I got big dick energy if that makes you feel better.
You have big dick energy?
Hell fucking no.
You were like, I'm gonna, I'm gonna try and make you
uncomfortable.
And then you just made yourself uncomfortable talking about
Like, what was it?
Like the anal fissures or something?
Anal fissures.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm just being the straight man of the group because I'm an
RP god.
So am I.
Is it RP or is it real?
We'll never know.
That's role play.
Is it, though?
Is it really RP?
Okay, I'm flying.
I'm out when I have a little pony.
Do I need to wait for anything?
Yeah, I'm going to wait for the egg.
I'll wait for the egg and then I'll go.
what can i do to be useful right now though
i'm still trying to find the fucking dungeon this dungeon's
so hard to find holy shit um when we need to butcher pals by
the way we should butcher the cow no we need to butcher
chicken it's only chicken oh it's only chicken yeah but we
have a lot of them on oh because i because i need the i need
the meat from the cow and i need the meat from the boar Not
right now, though.
I mean, we don't have the kitchen yet, so there's no kitchen
yet.
Wait, you're a high enough level to do it now.
We just don't have the materials.
We just don't have the circuit boards.
Nah.
All right.
Yeah, I gotta fly out of here then.
I'm just trying to find the dungeon.
Guys, am I going the right way?
Guys, we're trying to find the cavern of the Dune dungeon.
I don't know.
Excuse me, sir, do you know where the cavern of the Dune
dungeon is?
There's no holes anywhere!
Where the fuck are the holes?
I'm over-encumbered.
Oh, also, uh, Lily, this applies to you and me.
Make sure that you have at least 40 pals registered in your
decks today because there's a big difference between 30 and
40.
You get, like, 20 points versus 50 points.
I have 22.
We can probably just drop them to each other.
No, no, you have to catch them.
You've got to catch them.
I have to catch them.
Wait, open up this egg, then.
Hatch this egg.
Whatever this common egg is.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I think I found a dungeon.
I think I did it.
All right, let's go.
Okay, I don't know if this is the right one.
Oh, my God.
Please, for the love of God.
Okay.
Please.
I'm gonna make some common Okay, I found that to that
matter.
All right.
I'm making a base right now.
I still need to get I still need to get three more pals Guys
to get the 50 points.
I'm putting the base up now.
So I need you guys to get over here.
Can you can you give me one second just to get Wait, wait,
we have three bases?
Yeah, yes.
Well, you can just put it down.
Yeah.
Wait, I know, but I can't put it because we I cannot be able
to any more bases Oh, wait, do we have a third base?
built oh yeah you can just destroy mine fuck it we bought
someone destroy it and then we do this dungeon right now
where is it i can't so the right what do you mean you can't
i'm literally in front of the dungeon what do you mean this
one okay i'm gonna dismantle it hold v on it all right let
me know what i can build it okay is everybody ready to do
this dungeon no i'm trying to let me put the egg in last egg
last egg you need coal don't be having up no quartz oh
quartz oh okay uh what are you done sure for you'll there's
an egg for you uh if you want to open up that egg yes let me
do that get over here right now right now it took me five
minutes to this dungeon i'm gonna fast travel around find
some to catch it i didn't touch yet
okay are you wondering i'm good are you guys already final
egg is in i'm getting quartz toky how many times do you have
to stay at mother finish your quartz
oh wow we are we are we have so many refining already we're
doing great we're gonna we're gonna get this uh base is
gonna be 20 in no time All we need is the circuit boards.
It's faster!
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try and find...
Let's go!
Oh no, he's broken again.
I'm gonna fucking catch more stuff then.
While I wait.
No, I'm stuck.
Why am I always stuck?
There you go.
Can I catch this?
Level 35, I should be able to.
Okay, I'm gonna check that off the list.
Uh, okay.
So, all of the breeding stuff, I can just hide.
I don't need this anymore.
Oh, we can still make a dire howl, but I was kind of like...
Wait, did you clip the...
Did you already clip the...
We're waiting for it to hatch.
Okay.
Um, but the dire howl, is it like worth doing?
No.
I feel like it isn't.
You have to get the three passive moves.
We have the right things.
yeah I don't only a common egg so it's like fucking 10
minutes for egg oh okay if it's 10 minutes per egg then
that's fine okay I guess I can try to do they need cake
though yes fuck off okay then let's not do it let's not do
it I don't think it's worth it because I feel like we should
put our time in something else at this point yeah let's do
something else yeah because like we we really need catch up
on some points since we haven't really been farming points I
get the bosses let's go yeah that's a lot of points um okay
are we ready to go to the dungeon i'm getting quartz he's
getting quartz we had all right i'm gonna come get quartz
with you then yeah help him get quartz well actually oh wait
we can't drop a base anymore all right we can't i mean i can
destroy this base right now i'll destroy it i mean if quartz
is just something your mind you just drop me in then i'll
mine it in no time i'm not even kidding i'm gonna destroy
the base then later no no it's okay it's okay it's okay yeah
all right it's okay i can just fly over it's it's fine
there's a town where's the town okay give me a compass
direction chat i need a compass direction i can grab the
town oh there it is never mind i see it it's right there
wait what the fuck what the fuck what the fuck What the
fuck?
What the fuck?
No, no, what the fuck!
I fucking died!
I went to the Anubis and I didn't have the tropical armor on
and I fucking just died instantly.
Because I took it.
I forgot.
That's okay.
It's alright.
It's fine.
I'll just make myself a new armor.
Bro.
No.
Not like this.
I'm ready to go to the boss.
Are you fine?
Okay, I'm coming over.
What the fuck?
Okay, all right.
I'm just saying, like, I might as a girl.
All right, head over to the dungeon.
Hold on, wait.
When you're, when everybody's ready, head over to the
dungeon.
It'll take me one minute, just one minute.
Okay, it's okay.
I'm grabbing the fast travel in the town.
Or later.
I'm just gonna go pick up my shit.
Okay.
There we go.
You know what though?
That's, that was actually a speed strat because now I don't
need to eat.
Yay.
It was intentional by design.
Alright, I'm at the, I'm back at the base whenever
everyone's ready.
I'm ready to fast travel.
I'll wait here.
Alright.
I'm in.
I'm coming.
Lily, are you close?
I'm very close.
Where is she?
Oh, there she is.
I was like, don't worry about it.
Wait, why are you here?
Did you die?
Where are you?
Hello.
But also, I'm catching paths I don't have yet.
I skip so many.
Oh my god, when you're naked!
Don't worry, Bonnie.
Okay, okay.
It'll be fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
All right, okay.
Don't get killed by these guys with flamethrowers.
All right, guys.
Don't die.
Don't die to these guys.
Just run.
These are very high levels.
We have to get to the...
Sure, we have to get to the dungeon.
we can't because or those oh they'll die oh just keep ready
as long as everyone has a wolf it should be fine oh yeah
yeah what fucking wolf i've got a flying thing i don't just
don't die we need you alive so we can get this done i don't
know what oh jesus oh okay i don't know i was following you
we're doing it live oh i love doing this live i can't even
get up okay i got it i got it it's not No, I'm alone with
the dudes!
Oh yeah, it's over here.
Okay.
First try, baby.
Don't worry about the dudes!
Wait, I'm about to get fucking flamethrower to death, I
think.
No, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Just run past them.
Yeah, just...
I'm almost there.
Alright.
We're...
We're basically at the dungeon, Schrefer and I, we can try
and kill it together here.
Wait, I'm not- I'm not there yet.
Okay, well wait.
It's a pyrin.
i'm gonna put my univolt whoops all right you guys ready no
we need small peepie we're small peepie my small peepie is
really busting her to get over there where is she
performance i don't even see her i've got anxiety come on
you're almost are you stuck i'm stuck oh i'm getting off i'm
going yeah i'm stuck it's okay i'm coming okay we're I'm
coming, I'm coming.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
I've arrived.
Alright, here we go.
So sorry.
I'm here.
Do I have to hit it for it to count?
No, no, we just have to...
You just got to witness.
We just have...
Don't die from this.
I'm witnessing a murder.
It's okay.
Just like, yeah, just stay far away.
We have to just have to kill it, but you can capture it if
you want to.
Alright.
Do you want to capture it, sure, for?
I can try.
I don't know what the percentage is.
though yeah i don't know either if we it's like super low we
just fucking kill it oh my god
go tanking oh he's almost dead um retreating mine it's six
percent just kill it just okay okay grass type versus fire
what's the worst thing that can happen it didn't want to
join the family now it must die Now it must die.
Alright, nice.
You know the rules.
Picture, picture.
Clip, clip, clip.
We did it.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip, clip.
Amazing.
I hereby confirm I have witnessed the murder.
I was here.
I participated.
Alright.
I am guilty.
Alright, next dungeon.
Next dungeon.
Why don't you find it?
Alright, you guys can leave now.
You guys can leave.
I'll go find the next one.
I'm gonna let me know you guys I'll leave and I'll dismantle
this I left You should let me dismantle Okay yeah you can
dismantle it Yeah Okay I'm gone Are you gonna dismantle this
year for?
Yeah Alright I'm gonna Fucking head somewhere else then
Smoke peepee's still at that base No I'm not No I'm out
She's out I'm out too I'm gonna go Find The I'm gonna go to
the other sanctuaries And then I'm going to make a base near
the courts.
Yes, please.
That'd be super helpful.
I'm going to make...
I want to make the...
Actually, we can do the photos later then.
I'll just find the other dungeon.
Oh, do I have any food on me?
No.
Is there any food at base or no?
Check the PAL food thing.
There should be at least some honey and some other stuff
because I'm done with the cakes.
I don't need to make any more cakes.
Okay, I'll eat the honey then.
Yeah, we're not breeding anything.
Sounds like, what is it with flesh tubers and quartz?
I mean, if you can avoid eating the honey, that's probably
the harder one for us to...
Okay, I'll get the egg.
Okay, I'll get the milk then.
I...
Okay, because my pals need milk.
Need milk?
Yeah, if we want to actually just fill the ranch with, like,
chickens, we can just have a buck ton of eggs.
Or fill it with the cows, and then we can have...
milk we need a production assembly line let's see what do i
need dude i'm gonna find the other i'm finding i'm gonna go
find the other dungeon okay uh volcanic cavern dungeon
that's a level 40 that is all the way down here on the edge
but where is the where the how the fuck do i get there sure
are you okay with like destroying the base later when i find
the dungeon uh yeah i mean just let them farm some quartz
real fast okay as long as soon as you have the base just let
me know and then i'll get the quartz like this way okay
taking like 10 minutes max all right here i'll go i'm
heading over to the volcanic dungeon oh hey there's some
chicken i can kill for food oh yeah we need to take that
photo in the in the crater too i don't know where how to
find that what's this uh there's like a there's a lift monk
statue in the middle of the crater i guess and we have to
take a photo with it but we need we all need that advanced
armor and i just don't think it's worth it so i mean you you
can live if it's like one second you'll be fine right yeah
we can like whatever yeah like you just need photo yeah just
a little burn is not too bad you know yeah yeah like where
you're some coward all right i'm making the pal box at the
kill you so i can eat your meat there you go i got enough
meat now all right tiramako heading for the other dungeon
where the fuck that is the pal box we how much how much time
do you need sure for to get the hard bosses i need the i
need this is an oh my goodness the only thing that's
stopping you right now and it's just a quartz right the
course that's stopping you from making those balls because i
need the circuit boards but i got yeah we need to make the
circuit we need to make the oven first before we can use the
circuit boards for anything we can get that do you think an
hour is enough for you to catch the bosses what the fuck is
that yeah i mean they die fast all right so getting to them
that's the problem you just need to make sure we get
everything ready for sure for in an hour so then he can
speed run catching the hard bosses i'm working on it yeah he
just dropped me at the quartz i'll but i made the base there
all right lily it's time go pal go lily pal go i'm going
travel point and I'll be right there.
Do we need a special armor to survive there?
Just Tundra.
You need the cold armor.
Oh, just kidding.
You need cold armor.
Then I'll have to make that first.
Unless you don't need it right now.
You can just drop it for me.
If you have any, if you have a fire resistance armor or
anything, I can buy you two shirts.
I do have a fire resistance.
Oh no, this is a heat resistance.
Oh, I found the dungeon i found it already oh nice okay sure
for it's time to destroy that base not yet not yet we need
that quartz but i found it mine the quartz i don't give a
fuck if you found it or not you want me to catch those
legendaries or what okay i'll mark it i'll mark it where am
i i'm gonna mark this right now it's like 250 minutes so we
have like lots of time for this
That was fast, though.
I didn't expect to find that.
Alright, I'm gonna really quick just get this fast travel.
Alright.
I found the... Oh.
There we go.
No, that's fucking ore.
Ore.
Oh my god, this one was...
Okay, I'm at a fast travel.
There's a town along the south coast.
Okay.
Oh, there is.
Okay, I found that here.
And...
Is that the one?
why did i that's your nerf west guys i'm not high level
enough to do a legendary sure first the only closest one
yeah i don't think i'm gonna be killing a legendary yeah and
if he can't kill that today i can't kill a legendary i mean
i can probably kill it i mean we can get points from killing
it yeah we still get half points from killing yeah i mean
180 is better than nothing and they're cold in my mind i can
mine it don't worry well i can give you really close you
need like cold armor right resistance okay i can give you i
can get you one i'm going back to base and i'll make you one
nice i have to quads in no time uh let's see no no it's so
long let me see outfit okay i think i don't know sure if
it's a normal tundra outfit okay or does she need like the i
don't know all right i'm just gonna make a normal one then
maybe it'll be fine i know i can buy two undershirts i know
if you have heat resistance i can buy two cold i do have
heat resistance yeah then i'll just go buy the two
undershirts it would be bing chiling actually I don't know.
Chat says high or low protection is better, so I'll give
you...
I'll make it a normal one then.
It's okay.
I'm making her pelt right now.
Okay.
Oh, no, my pelt's hungry.
Wherever I can find the higher crafting area, because this
is a fucking mess right now.
Yeah.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Cold, resistant pelt.
I'm not having any luck here.
I thought that there was going to be a bunch of...
ports here there's none here uh where are you here in the
base uh
drop there you go boom thank you wham bam now you can go
farm stuff back to palling let's see oh just palling around
just palling around piling around try to see what i can put
away i have a lot of eggs but i don't think we need to hatch
i'm gonna fly back to the bay oh my god there's some lot of
forms i need um let's see i want to see i want pia to see
i'll catch the valet then where the is the valet okay all
right i'm so close to
Legendary.
Almost there.
Tell me more about your legendary balls.
Veilet, pal, world, location.
I'm Zoe.
I forgive you.
I don't actually want to know about that.
That's all I thought.
Make sure you check for lumps though.
Have you checked your balls?
I would say check for them yourselves but you guys don't
have balls.
Oh man, no balls.
I do have loads so bullish what the did i just do okay it's
fine yeah oh there it is i'll catch the village right now we
didn't we didn't want to have we didn't it's over here we
didn't want to have a lodging site that was i'm almost there
how much polymer can i make gooch
hey dude could you get out of the way i believe you still
haven't found any lucky pals we're not lucky i can't believe
it we're not lucky enough I haven't even seen Uno why aren't
you lucky because my stats on spawned I fucked up all right
I should be able to make legendary balls soon and then I can
start catching all right all right calm are you hungry right
now calm down They're legendary.
Calm down.
We heard your first time.
I'm going AFK 20 minutes.
No!
What did you do?
PP!
I'm so sorry!
This is it.
We're kicking.
We're kicking now.
Stop calling HR on me.
We're kicking.
We need a teammate replacement right now.
No.
I need to...
Alright, I'm moving the logging site.
I'm so sorry.
Ow.
Oh shit.
this is not good this is not good i'm not dodging okay did
we have a rough idea of how much coins we need in 150 oh i
think we might be fine actually oh shit at night it's very
cold oh my goodness i'm i think i'm dying at this wait what
i got what happened to the cold pill i guess at night it's
just too cold pp do you still need it quartz for anything uh
yeah so we need to make the circuit boards let me see so we
need to build the product assembly line um which requires I
believe 10 circuit boards so we need the quartz I think we
already and we need polymers too um but we should have
enough high quality pallet oil to make at least uh what's 36
divided by two we can make 18 we can make 18 polymers so we
can I think make that already uh but we pretty much want to
skip past it because we don't want to make the wait did we
advanced furnace oh never mind we already made it yeah i
made that okay okay yeah then we just need to legendary
balls okay cool then we just need to make the production
assembly line or the whatever it is uh the production
assembly line two the level two version i need 20 nails then
and i i think if we just get a few more cords i think that i
need to get some palladium fragments and some more iron
ingots Okay.
Or is it ingots?
I think I just need ore.
You just need ore.
Yeah.
Because then I can make the legendary balls.
Okay.
Okay, we have 200 quarts now.
Oh, shit.
That's a lot.
That should be enough.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Circuit boards are what level?
I don't know if I can assist.
But...
circuit boards circuit boards are from level level 35 okay
unfortunately i cannot help wait there's no palladium
fragment all right uh get ready to clip i think one of these
eggs wait no not this one can you make more palladium off of
the the mill or whatever the fuck can do hold up just
kidding go lily go Go, Lily, go.
Wait, what?
What happened to clipping?
Uh, wrong egg.
No!
The egg I needed still 21 minutes.
I know.
Sorry I got your hopes up.
No, no, clip, clip, clip.
No, clip, clip, clip.
No, clip, clip.
I'm so sorry.
No, clip, clip, clip.
I feel so nice.
Please forgive me.
No.
No forgiveness.
That's fair.
As soon as the night is over, they're gonna make the
fragments i'm gonna farm some manually in the meantime just
leave me alone i have 40 now i don't know how much you need
in total we have a hundred almost just a bunch you know all
right i'm gonna go manually i'm about to get a bunch of
palladium fragments okay mostly mostly just trying to get
iron ore all right iron ore look i can i'm gonna finish this
cement um Should we take the bat off of the mining station
and put him on ore?
I think we can just mine the ore.
Are you fine?
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm on it.
I'm getting pinged so hard right now.
I'm getting...
Because we also need to rock for like the fragments.
So I'm like, ah, shit.
Turns hat around.
Mining away.
You can move the base whenever now.
Okay.
Let me see if I can catch this fucking Veilet, and then we
can do that thing.
Oh, please.
Please just don't kill me.
I'm so low.
I'm going to force this.
I can't.
Don't be kidding me.
What?
Okay.
I cannot aim right now.
now all right please don't kill me please don't no no i
wanted to make the chill it saddle that was scary chillette
the best a man can get
oh i'm trying please it's five percent i have 37 i have 37
balls 37 balls i have 37 giga balls i will force this it's
five percent You're gonna force your ball.
Get in here!
Get yourself in here!
You stupid dog!
I'm sorry, there you go.
Clip, clip, clip, I got it!
Clip, clip, clip!
That's gonna be an OSHA violation.
I'm calling HR right now.
Alright.
Okay, anyway, I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna repair and then we can do the dungeon.
Are you guys all ready for dungeon?
Yes.
Yeah.
Alright, alright.
I'm just mining ore at the moon.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
PP bot, I did it.
I got the valet.
They're so proud of you.
They're so proud.
Alright, where are you?
Okay, I'm gonna repair my armor, and then we can do the
dungeon.
Alright, I'm gonna take half of this milk.
I need the milk.
Wait, no, fuck that.
Can you guys hatch the...
There's, like, lots of frozen.
I'm gonna hatch these.
What?
Why am I aiming?
We got a mouse, Mao, cat, Christ.
And, uh, another Mao Christ.
Okay.
Uh, where the fuck is the repair bench?
Uh...
There's two repair benches.
Yeah, I got it.
Okay, I'm going to go make the base now for us.
Okay, cool.
All right.
We only need 10 circuit boards, right?
We need a lot, but we need 10 for right now.
I added some more.
Did you guys destroy the base yet?
Did you destroy the base yet or no?
You're able to do that yourself.
Oh, I should be.
Oh, yeah.
And I get the materials automatically, right?
the electric kitchen if you want to make that right now uh
sure we only need five circuit boards for that and then um
for the exception for the uh assembly line two we need 10 so
we need to make like 15 circuit boards we need more high
grade oil then i put some high grade oil in the chest
because i've fucking killed a lot of people wait do i have
am i holding some no i'm not holding any we have 17 minutes
and then an hour left sorry we have like one hour and 16
minutes left so okay we need to like speed run some stuff
after that mark and our mark we should start taking photos
of like petting the palace yeah just to be sure do you want
to go do the dungeon now then yeah i'm heading over there
for us now okay and getting that dungeon right where the
Fuck did I put oh, it's over here.
All right I'm gonna destroy Where is the other base?
Okay, I'm dismantling the quartz base then.
It's the one.
Shit, where is this?
We're good on quartz It's the one next to the quivern,
right?
Is that is that the base?
Uh, the one next to the quivern I don't see the map, but
it's the one above Anubis We we still need the Anubis one, I
think.
I don't know what that was uh the one above and can you guys
like head there so i can see where it is because i don't i'm
worried i'm gonna get the wrong base uh okay the the one
that's like do you see the quivern yeah the base that's near
the quivern don't destroy that oh okay so the one above the
yeah the one the highest one right yep yep the highest one
you can destroy that yeah all right yep okay i'm Is it near
anything?
We'll be base level 20 once we do pretty much just the
production line, I think.
And then, because we already have the electric.
So we should be automatically level 20.
We just make the...
I needed to make.
Head over.
Assembly line and the electric cooker.
Electric kitchen?
Yeah, electric kitchen and the assembly line too.
All right, guys, you can head over now.
I made the base.
Also, we have 400 ore.
You can kill whatever you need while we do the dungeon.
Nice.
All right, I'm waiting.
all right i'm looking for you at the base okay on my way
we're here waiting my wet whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey it's pretty over here it's up here pp all right i'm
just gonna grab this left monk i'm gonna check what the last
dungeon at the fine oh dang it's mega pretty over here i see
the sacred mountain dungeon how would level Do we have to be
for that?
Level 45.
I think we can keep that.
Yeah, I think we can pull it off.
Well, sure, 4 and I can.
But, like, you guys might get ins to die.
Yeah.
We'll just be in.
We just need a lot.
You've got a shield, right?
A shield?
No.
Oh, I lost it.
Should have made you a shield.
You had my loot.
My shield was in there.
Oh, wait.
Does that mean?
I've got your shield.
Wait, hold on.
Here, I'm going to drop it.
Are you near me?
yeah let's see all right here's your shield let's go i do
have a shield you got a shield let's go what love are you
right now sure for 47 47 oh you're almost 50 we have a one
of the achievements to get to level fit get a pal level 50
yeah i'm coming over there just gonna wait let me see i
guess after that to go travel to the sanctuaries after that
i i'm here all right oh oh shit oh what happened oh i'm
gonna go inside before i die yeah just get inside yeah let's
go yeah let's go inside yeah let's enter all right let's go
find let's go find the oh yeah we just don't make sure you
don't get hit just keep running wait did you get wolf
finally pee pee we forgot to fucking bring it though oh boy
I might die actually No I'm so sorry I'm so sorry just fly
just keep flying just keep flying I mean I'm looking back so
if she does get down I'll fucking run back to her I'm
running I'm running I'm so sorry I made the saddle and
everything but I forgot to grab no it doesn't hurt this lava
doesn't Oh, is it here?
No, not this way.
No, okay.
It's okay.
They're all a little bit borked right now.
It's not this way, so we're turning back.
Okay.
It's so bright, Jesus.
I know.
It's like, yeah, I know.
Oh, shit.
Which way did you guys go?
Look for it!
This way?
Okay.
We'll find out.
We'll find it.
We'll try and find it.
Oh, wait, you don't have any pallet of saddles?
No.
Oh, no.
Well, yeah, I do.
I've got Wyvern, so I not that way okay not this way okay
yeah just fly i think it's just convenient at that point
it's just doorways it's only door i think it has to be this
right side then yep should be at least um handing over yeah
yeah it's here all right cool cool cool it's here let's go
fight are all here just gotta wait for pp yep i'm right here
all right let's go i am consenting to witnessing a murder
all right here you go let's go kill I am consenting to
witnessing a murder right now.
911, please.
There's a murder happening right now.
Oh my god.
I have no arrows now.
All right.
Go, Pen King.
Go, little guy.
You got this.
Well, I'm just gonna watch.
I don't have any fucking weapons anymore.
Yay, murder.
Yay.
You gonna catch him?
No, we just flip.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
We got it.
All right.
All right, nice.
Yay.
Woo-hoo!
Let's see, I'm at 39 now.
Someone fucking opened this.
Yeah, I made the palcifice.
I put my pal out there to die.
All right, I'm gonna go to the wildlife sanctuaries for us.
All right.
That sounds like a good idea.
Alright, let's get out of here.
I'm gonna try and start catching the boys.
Wait, what are you doing?
Did you build the electric cooker already?
Where's the...
What?
You built the electric cooker?
Or do we not have enough still?
I built the electric kitchen.
Oh, okay.
I think like either PP or Lily...
Oh no, there's not enough electricity.
Yeah.
Should work on the cheeseburger and the hot dog then.
Yeah, we need to...
Yeah, we just need to get the stuff built and that's it.
We do.
We got the kitchen now.
You got the kitchen now?
Yeah.
But you already built it?
okay yeah so you guys can i sick all right okay let me check
my notes sure for we'll get the hard bosses i'm gonna go get
fly to the sanctuaries okay uh mazzerina cheese we need milk
flour and tomato so we need two tomato seeds we can get the
tomato seeds from the wandering merchant who's in the sand
area so actually we might need to go back there
Uh...
Can anybody go to Dune Shelter and buy three tomato seeds?
I don't have the fast- I don't have money.
Where's Dune Shelter?
I have money.
Um...
I can do it.
I can buy tomato seeds.
I have six.
Six!
All right.
I have six tomato seeds.
I'm gonna make some arrows real fast.
Why can't I pick it up?
There we go.
All right.
I'm gonna make tomato...
Oh, tomato plantation.
Um...
Uh...
Can we get more coal?
What level do you need to be to do the tomato plantation?
I can go get more coal.
Do we still have the coal farm?
Okay, so Lily go get coal.
Peepie.
No!
I'm one level too low to make the tomato plantation.
Okay, I can make it.
I can make it.
Can you make lettuce plantation too while you're at it?
Yeah, I can.
Let me get my arrows and then I can make it.
And then after that, we can.
Before and I do our jobs or other jobs.
Okay.
okay what level is lettuce and tomato uh 33 and like 30
something 35 35 is not that uh 36 there is nope it's 33 38
is lettuce i can't find a tomato tomato is 32 sorry 32 and
38 um doesn't matter where i put it does not matter okay as
long as pal's gonna reach it it doesn't We don't have can
you pass me the tomato and lettuce seeds?
Yeah, I don't have lettuce seeds Okay, I can buy lettuce
seeds later.
Can you give me a tomato and I'll just yep, there's a tomato
We can get the burger done first then.
All right for the Tomato for the mozzarella meat we need two
tomatoes flour milk and we need to kill a mazerina Um, I can
kill a mazerina.
I'm putting the tomato plantation.
No, you should focus on other stuff the tomato plantation at
the bottom there was no more space cool and then i'll go get
the lettuce i'll go i'll go manual it do you have a general
idea of how much coal you need else i'll just grab
everything yeah just grab whatever you can uh wait did we
make the production belt too not yet okay i mean i need more
high grade uh do you need more here i dropped the tomato
seeds behind me thank you uh i'm trying to go kill the boss
as well yeah sure for yeah i'm gonna i'll take care of the
the food i just need the lettuce plantation that's all um
okay i can buy the lettuce plantations right yeah you can
buy lettuce seeds i think from the same vendor uh just like
this it doesn't matter which town right no well hold on let
me take a look i put it in the notes uh lettuce lettuce uh
okay the wandering merchant in dune shelter it's the guy
it's like the desert one i might be fucked here i found it
oh just run just run just run you can give i'm cucumbers
wait i don't have money no one gave me money let me give you
money yeah no one gave me money are you here this goodbye
okay here i'm dropping i'll drop my money okay i have 400 uh
holy look you're so slow all right make sure you get three
three minimum okay
I'm gonna butcher wait I need to make a machete because I
see a rush roar over there so I'll just I'll go get that
meat right now get that meat yeah where the fuck is he um
machete nope nope you okay nope oh I don't think she's okay
she sounds all right I was like maybe that disappeared if I
tell them point back and forth but um yeah there's no ways
how many wandering merchants are there oh okay i got some
items in stock lettuce we're gonna go wait do they have to
be alive to use the meat cleaver or is it a dead situation
alive okay that's why it's in humane
gotcha because when they're dead it doesn't taste as good
chat you need to watch this because it's important to
remember where your food comes from i'd be very thankful I
got this I'm gonna plant the lettuce stuff then um three
right I got three
No, oh you stinker eventually they'll do spawn that's okay.
I can just get berries Actually, I wrote our whole base um
lettuce Um, oh my god, there's like we have like barely any
space to fucking put this now I can get rid of the breeding.
I get rid of the breeding we're not Okay, yeah, can you get
rid of it?
And then I can plant this.
Disassemble.
Nice, alright.
Okay, disassembled.
Alright.
There you go.
Thanks, I'll build it.
Okay, now I can help you build.
Alright, I'm gonna go fly the fucking sanctuary for real
now.
Thank you!
I'll cook.
For real, for real, for real.
I got you.
We finished the breeding, now we just gotta do the cooking.
Finish your first, gotta...
Finish your first, like, speed run catching the bosses.
Yep.
Yeah, you guys should focus on bosses.
Yeah, I already got all the mediums.
I mean, I'm missing one more medium, but I can catch that
later.
I'm just gonna work on getting the sanctuaries first,
because it's not that difficult.
Uh...
Let's see...
It's right here.
All right, we come.
We have...
We're almost at an hour, Mark.
Maybe at the 45-minute mark we started cutting.
Slime drater, die drater.
I'm not anything to drink and...
three hours oh my god go hydrate pal world is like the worst
game for my health because i forget to drink i forget to
like i like shrimp i just like holy shit holy fuck hydrate
that's not healthy i like literally become like a sword art
online protagonist when i play pal oh god just like forget
my i have a body the worst thing to be i'm like i'm like
three t's in that's gold catch up like a big one just for
you just for my favorite pal lily yippee our best pal all
right i killed one of the boxes what you killed not captured
oh i captured oh clip clip clip sure if we're captured wait
which one was i drink a lot of water i'm gonna have a pp
problem in like a second bro you are you are the pp cybelex
okay how didn't you have pp problem wait cybelex my throat
feels so much better it felt so bad i was like why do i feel
terrible they're still here no way why do i feel so bad all
right peepie mod sure if we're caught a pal cyberlex clip
clip clip remember the clip clip did it okay just to be sure
hot dog what what all right just need that lettuce uh and
then i gotta get that uh cow meat um where's the nearest cow
um it's where the bandworm bandworm where we caught the
bandworm we're 10 lace right now that's that's not that y
'all top 10 top 10.
i think the moment we we take pictures of petting the pals
we will skyrocket because that's the one thing that we
haven't really done we gotta make our little petting zoo we
gotta put out oh we gotta put out all the humans too at the
very end when we're ready to just say like we don't care
about materials i think no at the last 10 minutes we can do
that yeah that's fine all right okay do we require more coal
or do you need more coal what do you need for for you i feel
like hyper spear materials is like the thing we need the
most at that point right yeah i have seven legendary spears
queued up iron ore okay iron ore got it let me just grab one
anubis and the palladium fragments those are always yeah
yeah I need those two later as well um let me know whenever
you're sure for whenever you're ready to do the black market
I can do it with you so I can aggro it together dude that's
that's hype I'm excited to see this done like legit wait
people do it wait what I didn't know you I didn't know you
could do it any other way than like the the exploit way.
What?
There, people do it.
There's an exploit?
No, not in this game.
There's no glitches in this game at all.
There's an exploit for the black market.
I have to catch a legit.
What do you mean?
Because I guess normally you would use the, you would use
the, the, the, the fire.
Well, I didn't know that.
I fucking, fucking did it the hard way.
no that's why you a pro oh come on i'm very slowly flying
over there i'm just gonna you know i'm just gonna all right
i'll go get i'll go get a a pal i'm gonna go catch one of
the or kill one of the cows i guess last hour stop me at the
clock stop Stop.
I'm a sighting pal.
That means they're like, what if I pick up this berry
though?
You get ready to clip.
Get ready to clip.
Here comes the last breed that we're doing.
Ozark was born.
Let's go.
Clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip.
All right.
I got German tied.
Clip.
Sure for two.
Clip, clip, clip.
Oh my God.
I'm still on.
Lord of the sea.
All right.
We got Jormantide and the breeding Ozrek, whatever his name
is.
Lettuce.
Lettuce and then I can make the hot dog and then I'll just
make the cheeseburger.
I just need two Maserina meats.
Oh my god, I've been flying forever.
Where did he go?
Stop.
Okay.
Leaving your post.
Don't, just...
I'm flying out of here.
I'm gonna be bald, I swear.
Please.
I'm gonna catch this guy just for now.
Alright, was it over here?
For the power register.
That was the only one?
No, I don't think so.
No!
Stop killing everything!
Okay.
Back to mining.
Mining.
no way over to the here okay directly directly west all
right all right i'm gonna go kill myself a cow nice come on
bessie yeah are you fucking no you in the way come on
swimming cow that's gonna be some good meat come on i should
have been flying to this thing but I want to catch this for
a registered cow.
Wait, what the fuck is wrong with that cow?
Can I get a different cow?
Oh, fuck off.
No.
Come on.
Why are you so hard to fucking catch?
It's like the cow knows that I'm trying to kill him or
something.
Maybe it's because you shot him?
Nah.
That can't be it.
I don't know.
you shot a cow i don't think so there's a sanctuary come
here dude yay extra meat all right cool we out peace
i'm almost there i feel like i've been flying for 50 years i
don't know how to get to the volcano thing i feel like i can
give you my armor and then you can get if you know where it
is i can I've never been.
Somebody in the base building competition built a base
there.
That's why I know it exists, but...
Oh.
Yeah, I don't know where that is, so I don't know how to get
that for us.
What are you talking about?
What's your floor?
What are we talking about?
The volcano.
The volcano effigy.
I mean, I can find it on the map pretty easily, but I don't
know if I can traverse the locale to get there.
I mean, I can give you my heat pelt.
primary and then you can get we'll do that later because i'm
trying to i'm making the food now okay i can get to i can
get to all the other team photos just not the whoa whoa just
not the volcano one all right be ready to clip we're making
the cheeseburger double checking not a hamburger definitely
cheeseburger all right cheeseburger start production yay
order up cheeseburger is done clip clip clip clip clip clip
We got the cheeseburger.
And for those who are not interested in cheeseburgers, we
will also have some nice hot dogs for you.
Just one second I gotta harvest the lettuce.
Why isn't the lettuce on the cheeseburger?
Why is it on the hot dog?
Different strokes for different folks.
Do any of you eat hot dogs with lettuce?
I mean, there's some like Japanese hot dogs with lettuce.
I've had some of those.
yeah so i'm at the are you guys ready to come over i'm at
the wildlife sanctuary one second i'm just harvesting a
lettuce what about you sure for no i gotta kill this boss
all right we'll just wait until he's ready to kill that boss
i'm just gonna put the base here first i have harvested a
couple more or oh don't go get a rock after all right base
is what's done so you guys can come over one over one second
it's gonna be about uh 30 minute 30 no that's fine just wait
until sure uh what all right i'm gonna do all right let's
see okay let us get how much more do we have for our base to
get to level 20 anyway uh all we gotta do is build that line
two and we're done line two and then we're high quality pal
pal oil fuel yeah you can get that from farming the what was
it the penguin no that's the other one The laxosaurus.
I can farm that later after...
Okay.
Uh, we're building... We're making the hot dog now.
The legendary powers...
Codes are done.
Legendary what?
Legendary spears?
Okay.
Clip, clip, clip!
Peepie mine!
Cooking is done!
Cooking mine!
Peep, peep, mine!
Hide.
Hide sheet, don't need it.
12, 14.
Hide, don't need it.
15 hide.
Don't need it.
Let's see what I need.
to do i don't need it oh i don't need that either yep all we
need is the do we did we make carbon fiber yet carbon fiber
uh i can make that i'm gonna buy how much power oil do you
need sure for do you know high quality how much an amount
how much is it about final man what you're the one making
Bro, there's so many things I have to do right now.
You think I'm going to remember all the fucking exact
numbers?
I thought you're perfect.
What happened?
Yeah, perfect at the things I want to be perfect at.
And that's not being perfect.
Perfect in my world.
Okay, other ways to farm high-quality pale oil.
I'm buying one of them right now.
The Wally Pops.
Wally Pops drop as well.
De Muds drop them.
Dig choices drop them.
So I think actually the Wally Pops is probably the fastest.
just an easiest way i got i got menacing medicine clip clip
clip we got menacing let's go mod pp mod we got medicine
make sure you clip it okay all right let's see i'm going to
i i dropped some i got five i just got five so i'm not sure
if that's enough i don't think so but like i just high
quality too high quality okay so i i put five in there um oh
my team's hungry i'm gonna just just go to the pal deck look
for relaxesaurus yeah i will kill those um do we have are we
good to go to take a photo now after i travel to a fast
travel spot okay we'll just wait for sure i'll kill dummets
in the meantime i'm gonna go kill some walley pops in the
meantime well sure we're gonna be able to be done soon
coming back soon so we should just head over now Okay, since
he's just flying over to fast travel.
It's to the far left
Is it hot or cold?
Um, I don't I can't tell my thing isn't showing you oh there
it's medium Actually, I have heat pelton, so I don't know it
could be cold.
Let me grab my chillit so I'm not Super fucking slow this
time.
I'm heat pelton.
It's just a photo.
It's not dungeon.
Oh JK Okay
All right, I wait.
I'm here.
All right, we're just missing lily and sure for he's still
he's still trying to find the fast point i know where it is
i just have to get there he's coming over i got six all in
the meantime how much all do we need suzaku a fucking one of
them oh he is yeah he is might as well just kill this guy
real quick What the fuck?
What the fuck?
He's on the way to the fast travel point.
What the fuck you want from me, man?
Alright, then we can just do other stuff while he does that.
Alright, let's do that.
I'm literally just about to catch him.
Did you catch him?
He's in the ball right now.
Alright, okay.
I don't think I'm back here.
I didn't even believe.
I can fly back.
I caught him.
Alright, clip, clip, clip!
We got Suzaku.
Oh, you know I gotta catch this Lovander though.
What the fuck!
Suzaku cut!
Clip, clip, clip, peepie mod!
Alright, shout out Lillian and I are here.
Lillian, peepie, Lillian and I are here.
Hello.
I am here.
We're here.
I'm sorry, I'm just trying to stay awake.
Yellow.
It's so fucking late.
We're almost there one hour left!
We're almost there!
Almost there!
Wait, wait, wait.
You signed up for this war soldier.
You have to finish it.
Oh, I'm working.
I'm mining.
And I'm mining.
She's trying her best.
She's mining.
I'm mining.
She's mine.
Now I hit the button again.
All right, let me know what you get.
Eighth place.
We're in eighth place right now.
So cute.
We're just waiting for you.
I'm slowly watching him flying to the fast travel.
He's almost there.
Almost there.
Should have to travel across the fucking desert.
Also, I'm registered 40, by the way, in case that becomes
relevant later.
Yeah, I only have 29.
If we want to clip that, we want to clip that.
Okay.
I'm still catching a lot, so I'm good to go.
I have 50, so that's like 60 points.
Yeah, because I think there's like a big leap between 30 and
40.
It was like 20 points versus 50 points.
yeah all right here we go sure four is sure four is almost
there i'm literally watching all right clip clip we're here
i have like sanctuary two all right i'm leaving goodbye
goodbye goodbye i'm heading to the third one now i'm gonna
try to get some polywaps or whatever the fuck they're called
and get some high quality all right where the fuck is the
last because once we do that it will be it will be base
level it's cold how much do we in total i just got six while
waiting oh uh good question um really good question actually
wait what are your jobs right now shit don't don't hit me
i'm getting high quality pal oil and farm whatever people
tell me to okay what about you pp where what's your job at
the moment i'm flying back to base hold on uh i'm trying to
get high quality pal oil so we can finish the base okay so
both you're gonna do that all right yeah i'm killing damage
and i think she's calling they're killing woody pops for it
yeah but they're not out right now because it's nighttime so
i'm gonna come back for a sec they're gonna try and kill
these guys i'm not sure they care you can also we can also
go to the anubis base uh where they've got the dig choices
and the other one they also drop it no oh there two dummies
if we if one of us beats the tower does anybody else have to
be there no no we're just one of us yeah i already did two
towers all right perfect oh no i'm All right, I'm gonna go
to the end of the space.
Do I have to catch the mammary?
I'm going with Lily.
Hi, Lily.
The mammary?
Hi.
I already...
Welcome to my damage farm.
Oh shit, I'm freezing to death.
Yeah, I already did all the...
I did all the mediums except for the Botan.
Botan.
Or the Botan, yeah.
Your Oshi.
Why am I cold?
Actually, my Oshi's...
Why is the desert so cold at night?
What the fuck?
What happened to Botan?
He used the Oshi and her, too.
I discovered hosho Marines.
Why?
Oh, so Marine, this is...
Oh, there's another tower here.
Oh, it's all those... Oh, my... Yeah, you did discover
Marine.
There she is.
Okay, I got six more.
Dang, she's so hot, though.
She's so hot.
Why do they make her look like that?
I'm starving right now.
I might die before I could do anything.
Shit.
Oh, there's a waypoint here.
Okay.
Oh no, help.
Can someone revive me?
Lily, help.
I'm coming to you.
I got, I was defeated by this hot lady and I couldn't, I
couldn't help myself.
I'm so sorry.
Wait a minute.
I hear a shiny.
It'd be a shame if I tried by catching her while reviving
you.
Oh no.
That's okay.
It's better.
Oh my god, she's behind you.
She's behind you.
Fuck.
stay in are you guys all okay what's going on okay holy what
the is going on oh oh thank you thank you holy oh andel's
dumb it's perfect oh yeah let's kill him let's go okay okay
bad worm
uh high quality pal oil three did you sure for her did you
are you lucky enough to catch your lucky I want to keep one
I want to keep one I want to keep one Clip Clip Clip He
didn't want to be kept So he can die Clip Shreffor's Lucky
pal Hey Congrats We really have not seen A lot of lucky pals
Shreffor you did it You're finally lucky Oh my god So proud
of you I want to die Alright Lily can I have all the high
quality pal You have right now I'll just take it back nine
on me.
All right.
I'll take it.
Why do you want to die?
You have so much to live for here Where are you it's falling
down like what oh, oh like marine.
Oh, thank you.
I got it.
I'm the fat picture Thank you, but if you live long enough
she'll eventually know you right Anubis, why are you so
fucking tall?
Oh shit.
Hey, oh, he's a boss battle with him.
Oh, I don't want that um we already got we got a lot of
powwow we might be they've been doing pp and lily have been
doing pal uh powwow i'm grabbing some more i've got a damn
it i've got 12.
what oh what the fuck no i don't want to fight him no no no
no no no no guys are you guys free for the third sanctuary
because i'm already here yeah i'm getting the hell out of
there a new biz was attacking okay i'm gonna be there i'm
gonna be there in like uh 30 seconds yeah i'm just running
back to base with uh the oil
all right here we go how many uh sure do you know how many
we need uh pal oils he does not okay all right i'll bring
you what i got all right i got the oh i didn't get my pal
oil for a kill oh first let me disassemble this base okay
put it in i got base ready for your new buddy on my way
making my way down down flying very slowly at medium speed
it's at the very top right but I'm trying my best the base
is at the very very top right I'm ready whenever my pals are
starving so I need you guys to get over here oh shit it's at
top oh I see you Okay, I'm flying away because uh, let me
know what you guys are there.
There is a I just came into danger Okay, yeah, there's a pal
that's very angry.
Oh, I need you guys to all be there at the same time Okay,
are you guys all heading there?
I'm here.
Okay.
I'm just waiting for sure before they get there Mammoth
dropped 10 oil to kill by the way.
That is my line however Nerdfight sanctuary.
Clip clip clip clip clip clip clip clip.
All right, bye That was nice vacation, Bob.
All right, we did.
We got the sanctuary.
Okay, I'm fucking, I'm going home so I can...
Okay.
Clip, pee, bye.
All right, so I can get the...
I'm taking a look at what we need still.
We need more palladium fragments.
We need more palladium fragments?
You need some?
Okay, yeah, I can make some right now.
Some now.
Can somebody get Ignis out of the ground, though, while I do
that?
If they're at the box.
Ignis?
Yeah, he's, like, stuck in the ground.
Okay.
Yeah, I can.
He's back now.
Bigging fragments.
Um, let's see.
How much time do we have?
You guys want to do the petting now for now?
Just to get that over with.
Because we have like 40.
I'm on my way.
So all of us come over here.
Uh, let's do water first.
Let's just go in order.
And do water.
Alright.
Um, I'm bringing out the...
I'll do penking.
I'm bringing up the flock.
Are they only...
water yeah only water type so they can't first i think they
can right they should be able to there's oh it doesn't say
it says of the same element so i have the flock out there's
it i don't think it matters i have a brawn cherry aqua
should we ask admin at at admin can we can the pals be mixed
type we figured it out for pal petting, like water and
grass.
Okay.
You're gonna kill Anubis?
It's gonna be so fast, sure for it.
Okay.
You know how much time we have left?
It's called time efficiency.
All right, fine, go kill Anubis.
Wait, where the fuck is Anubis?
Bro, why do, why are these?
No, the fucking boss.
No, he's just talking about the, oh yeah, yeah, they can be
mixed.
They can be mixed.
back here i i i get back in here how do we pet i forgot how
to pet and what the is he who was here before all right guys
we are let's go downstairs and pet them because there's too
many pals here wait did you bring them downstairs wait no
i'm going down to the mound so we can all like get the
screenshot of all of us we got all these other pals blocking
it yeah i was ready we had to do this all right i have mine
how do i pet does everyone mine you press the oh wait I'm
sorry.
I don't know how to do on keyboard.
You're probably on controller.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Okay.
Sure.
Do you remember how to pet?
Hell fucking no.
How do we pet?
Hold four.
You hold four.
Okay.
I'm petting him.
What do I have right now?
All right.
Screen chat.
Wait, no, we're all, none of us are going to get there.
Get closer.
Get close.
No, I, I got it.
I got it.
Do we have to save the photo?
Yeah, yeah.
But I wasn't even there.
You didn't get anything.
Get back here.
Get down.
of us no shy lily has to be down yeah it looks like it looks
like donkeys going absolutely crazy two one go there you go
all right water's done okay all right now what okay and then
we need grass grass all right good thing my bond cherry is
grass too so you can bet your bond cherry again okay um i've
got the kanzi oh wait no i'm gonna use my bet birdash all
right i've got a petalelia or whatever let's see all right
i'm down the hill all right i got birdash okay i'm ready oh
that's that's not grass all right oh my god why does he look
like such a handsome man are you guys ready Yeah.
Okay, I'm heading.
It's pet time.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
All right, grass is done.
Clip, clip, clip.
What's next?
Dark type.
That's enough.
Stop, stop petting.
Get out.
We need dark type.
Do I have dark type?
Okay.
Instant around.
Is he dark?
No, that's...
No, you see?
What?
That's neutral.
That's electric.
That's dragon.
Wait, what does dark type look like?
Oh, yeah, I do.
Van Worm is dark type.
a scope by element yeah i'm gonna do vanworm i'm gonna do
vanworm vanworm will be my fire and my dark okay i have the
i have a hoot for it i all right all right i'm ready on bet
i have i'm using the hoot are you guys ready yep yeah all
right we're all right petting
Clip, clip, clip.
What's the next one?
Duh!
Ice.
Lemonade my neck was dripping.
I don't think I have an ice.
Wait, does anyone have an ice for her?
Let me double check, but I don't think I have ice.
Oh, come on, we're getting raided.
Oh no, I have a penguin.
He's ice too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's ice.
That counts.
Yeah, yeah, that counts.
Well, we're getting raided right now, so...
It's alright.
Our base will take care.
I'm ready.
I'm ready too.
Okay, we're not ready.
Are y'all ready?
I'm coming down.
I can't clip.
All right.
I'm ready.
Three, two, one, go.
I'm pettying.
It's all right.
We don't care.
Just clip this.
In the middle of a fucking war.
It's okay.
the clip did we get the clip someone pick me up don't pick
me up where are you oh yeah i'm rising i'm rising why are
they level 40 what the oh i'm rising i'm rising don't move
don't rush me over here okay we need do we do we i'm rising
they actually in capped everyone i'm gonna vomit okay are we
good help me help me up where are you you're right on the
rock i'm trying to get to you oh i'm trying i'm fucking out
right now where are you going he's walking away everybody's
dead everything at base is dead okay i don't need anything
because everything's dead wait do okay we got a group let's
just keep petting until we're done with this let's keep
petting earth tight i'm gonna grab the sick ones and put
them back in the box so they can heal okay Oh my god.
I'm getting the earth type right now.
Ground, grass.
Where the fuck would be?
No!
My dragon and my ice was...
Is ground earth?
It's fine.
Or is there a separate...
I guess ground.
Yes, ground is earth.
Okay, I got the...
What am I being attacked by now?
I got the fudler then.
I have fudler.
Are you guys ready?
Yeah.
I'm at the bottom.
I'm sorry.
Ground, ground.
sorry give me one second earth is ground my bad i'm gonna
grab all the pals now okay earth fire electric dragon i'll
grab gyre howl wait is that earth no no gyre howl's neutral
uh i don't have an earth one i don't think i can give you an
earth yeah rush or rush or is earth i think he's dead right
now dead i have a rush or here i put in the base you can
grab that okay cool and then okay Let's go.
I have my fudler.
Let's go to the bottom.
I'm ready.
Alright.
Get over here.
You guys ready?
I'm ready.
Petting.
Pet, pet, pet, pet.
Pet, pet.
Wait, you both have...
You both have brush or...
One of you guys have to change it.
Okay, I can give you another one.
We have to redo this one.
But it has to be different, pal.
Yeah, it has to be different.
What is Bushi?
Is Bushi...
No, it's okay.
I have an extra.
There's a Duma.
Duma is...
I'll take Duma.
Okay.
All right.
Uh, okay.
You grab some...
Oh, fuck it.
Okay.
Are you guys ready again?
Yep.
All right.
Sorry about that.
I'm ready.
Pet, pet, pet, pet, pet, pet, pet.
Oh, he's so happy!
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Flip, clip.
all right now fire what's the next fire fire i got fire and
dragon i'm gonna grab a fire right now i should do i have
i'm doing a wire rim i need a fire van worm got them room
okay yeah okay um i got the fox park i'm using instant
around i'm getting fox park right now um are you guys ready
that up to me pet pet pet pet put clip oh my god all right
what's the next one uh next one is electric okay all right
beacon not i'm doing beacon i don't think oh wait i have a
meaning try are we gonna try and do the the kill
achievements with unique skills i don't think we have time
for that those are like not a lot of points either too let's
check up yeah i think we just focus on the other the easier
ones first because That might be too much.
Yeah, I got do we all have electric?
Someone has my electric like the little I'm petting.
Oh, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
I can just one.
I can steal a Grisble.
Oh, yeah.
Grisble?
Yeah, you can have it.
I'll just take him from the farm for now.
All right.
I'm ready.
One over here.
Pet, pet, pet.
Let me see.
Yeah.
Pet, pet, pet, pet.
I'm petting.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
All right.
What's next?
Uh, last one is dragon.
Yep.
I'm doing the van room.
I wonder if I can use the same pet for a different type.
Yeah, you can.
We'll find out.
Alright, let's go.
I'm ready.
I don't have dragon yet.
Let me grab my dragon.
Let me see if I have a dragon.
I might need someone to drop me a dragon.
Yeah, we might have to drop you, dragon.
Oh, I have a quiver.
I'm getting a quiver for mine.
Okay.
Um, wait.
Can you use...
You can use a...
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna use chill it for mine.
Sorry, Van Worm is not a dragon.
I'll use chill it.
Alright.
Oh shit, you're fucking used.
Yeah, I need a dragon.
I don't have a dragon.
Okay.
I can give you one.
I'm putting one...
Oh, I can use Azure Rob.
I can steal Azure Rob.
Yeah, you can use it.
Is Azure Rob dragon?
Yeah, probably.
Nice.
Okay.
Ready?
Yeah.
Pet, pet, pet, pet.
Pet, pet, pet.
Oh my god, you can barely see anything.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip, clip.
Okay.
They're just gonna have to trust in us.
Trust us, yeah.
Trust the process.
All right, PvMod, you should have two, four, six, eight
clips.
You should have eight clips there.
All right.
There we go.
We did it.
All right, back to killing bosses here for us.
Back to work.
Okay.
Pal, wait.
Can you make the thing?
Did we bring you enough?
yeah did we bring you enough or the uh you have enough for
pal high quality palo yeah for to make the the polymers to
make the yeah yeah i need six more refined ingots five six
more refined ingots all right no problems 21 nails wait
what's the second one five circuit boards five circuit
boards okay I can make five circuit boards.
All right.
Where the fuck are my nails?
I need the nails and the refined ingots.
And then we're huge.
What is pal metal?
Oh, that's for nails.
Oh, I can make nails.
Those are for the legendary spirits.
All right.
We're going to need to get those off the line to make more
refined ingots.
All right.
I'm going to.
Okay.
I need to steal some food.
I'm fucking hungry.
We only need six refined ingots.
Yeah.
we're we having a little bit of a problem in that everything
died yeah okay well we have like 30 minutes so you guys like
we let's try to speed run this sure foreign and i can finish
the rest of the bosses the we need to be at level 20 as well
to make the zoo with 20 people in it okay yeah all right uh
sure do you want to do the black marketeers right now with
me after i kill this okay after that then i'll you and i
will do the black marketeer thing second black markets here
oh um we can find i can find one easily uh i have them i can
try i'll find the second one right now and then try and mark
it oh very much okay what do we need i did the nails okay
okay there's one give us enough nails can you go get some
more power oil yeah like you get the power thank you thank
you there's one okay i don't want to do guys i don't want to
do the do it with so many people around us so there's one
here that i know let's see i have nine more pal oil i can uh
we need to butcher chickens as well right yeah okay now we
can do it really fast because we have so many chickens yeah
um okay how much power will still meet you know sure how
much power do we need for the polymer none we're already
done with that we we need what materials are we needing
boards so we don't need that six like six or seven refined
ingots 21 nails nails nails are done we just need to now i
now i caught the suzuku suzatsu i found the black marketeer
level 40 i found another one find ingot i'm gonna make as
many as it'll make all right and then i can kill them and
i'm also almost level 50.
all right nice ingot will be done by the time you get back
it's already at seven eight nine So if you just come, you'll
you'll have enough Now someone So are we missing anything
then still Clip, clip, clip, Susuzaki No, actually I think
we're good We don't need high quality Palo Alto actually PP
mod Susuzaki We just need the refined ingots If you can just
go catch a couple of pals So that you're Yeah, because I'm
gonna You just go catch pals Yeah Go go catch pals Sure,
four and I are just gonna focus on black marketeers right
now Okay I'm waiting for you on one of them yeah do you have
a do you have the waypoint for this i'm about to find out
see oh at the 10 minute mark we can do the chicken and the
human thing i'm looking at the global just to be sure
uh how hard is tower three i'm at you okay let's go follow
me it's like right here
There.
Dig toys.
Ow.
Here we come over here.
Do you want me to make more of the pal metal ingot?
I don't think you can.
I can.
Oh, can you?
Alright, then build it up.
Just make as many as I can?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm ready whenever.
Alright.
Fuck him up.
Let's go.
We gotta capture him.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's getting fucked up.
Yeah, he's getting fucked up.
I'm a little over-encumbered at the moment.
All right, be careful on the deeps, I guess.
I'm gonna...
My shotgun does a lot of damage to him.
My vampire shouldn't kill him, right?
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I'll reset him now.
Okay.
You can catch him now.
Fuck, which spear should I be using?
All right.
I have no idea, but we need to catch this.
fucker
okay come on come on nice 12%er let's go we got one of the
black marketeers we just need one more clip that clip clip
clip clip us catching that one send in get it later alright
let's go for the other one I have I marked it so just fall
uh I'm gonna need more spears I think then alright come come
back come back to base and build the thing then we have all
the materials you should need you go build it and then he
got to make more spears and I can set up the jail I can set
up the jail with the humans in it.
Treyfus, can you build...
No, it's not a Treyfus.
P.P.
Can you get more spheres for sure for them?
Yeah.
Because he needs me.
I have to start the thing.
Oh, yeah.
I made the pal metal for you.
I don't have the recipe for the spheres, though.
All right.
I'll go to the other marketeer whenever he's ready so he'll
know where it is.
I need palladium fragments.
Palladium fragments are done.
Let me grab them.
I'm going to get to the other one right now.
How many do you need?
As many as you can.
Alright, I've got 17 right now.
I should have had 46, but I don't even know what's up.
Go, Power Lover!
Go!
Okay.
Alright, I'm heading to the second market here.
What?
Okay, he's on the crusher again.
Lily's just catching pals right now guys she needs all the
pals she can get i just need pals preaching to the choir i
still need the nine nails and oh i need like apparently for
this more nails wrong thing wrong thing what do you need
nine nails oh okay nails done wow put them in a box okay
okay
in the it's not working i still need nine apparently wait
did i went the wrong one in the box is this the wrong area
yeah where do i put this thing uh anywhere you can that's a
reincarnated dude i can get rid of the down here we don't
need the we don't need these two farms anymore can you get
rid of this one right here uh wait which one this the
production what the and okay yeah i can see you're right all
right up here i'm jumping on oh shit fucking on i'll just
put it over down there fuck it okay sorry i became
over-encumbered yeah i went the wrong way for the black
marketeer it's inside the dungeon is that that actually
marked it correctly it's not a dungeon it's okay which one
are you going to i don't know i think it went the wrong way
there's one real close.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I might just go catch it right now.
Yeah, you can't go catch it.
You don't need me, right?
I can do the rest of the build if you did it.
All right.
There we go.
That's fine.
Yeah, I went the wrong way.
I found I just need luck.
Yeah, there's one underneath the desolate church.
Yeah, you can get that then.
I'll go.
I'm going to look at what else I can do.
I'll go get the...
There's still 20 minutes.
I can kill this other boss then.
Okay.
All right, I'm going to upgrade the base.
base level I'm hungry fuck okay is there more food like was
that assembly line two or was that assembly line one that's
assembly line two you need two to upgrade why didn't it why
isn't it registered on it doesn't it says that it's not
built uh let me head over and see I mean you can look at it
it says yeah no I got it you're bugged you're bugged I got
it like base level 20 clip Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip,
clip, clip.
Clip.
Pee-p-Mod.
There ya.
Base level 20.
I thought you were just bugged up.
I'm gonna build the prison.
Okay, build the prison.
Yeah.
I'll, yeah.
All right.
All right, viewing cage.
Okay, let's see.
Oh shit, viewing cage needs to be fucking huge.
All right.
I'm gonna go catch you this boss then.
Do we actually need this production assembly line or can I
just get rid of it now that we made it?
The number one or the number two?
number two because it's faster just get rid of number one
then all right get rid of number one can you make carbon
fiber on it uh yeah maybe let me check power oh wait no i
don't have the recipe so no uh you should have it or you
should for carbon carbon fiber yeah okay it's right here
okay the is my shit i've got mines defensive walls
uh wait i need a fucking fuck i need a we're in fifth place
right now yo yo sorry carbon fibers level 35 i can't make it
i can make it i'll make it i'll make it i can i can make it
it's okay sure you go do your bosses working on it i i i can
put it where's the high quality crafter i'm gonna just try
to make space wherever i can oh my gosh there's so many just
a regular assembly line right all right where's the assembly
line so i can make the fiber um down below where the trees
are all right i'll i'll set it up okay uh is it just carbon
fiber all right with coal yeah recall how much do you need
that's a bunch i'll do 30.
okay i'll put 30 up okay first try black market near seven
percent baby nice okay clip clip clip clip we got two clip
let's go clip clip put the both of them there because we
have two clips of us catching two um i'm taking 10 of the
tomatoes because i'm fucking hungry right now
uh i'm gonna go kill this one guy oh yeah i'm definitely
bugged i'd have to re-log that's okay i think i think it's
all right I'll make it work.
It's this way.
Anubis was bugged, so I couldn't kill him.
No!
I don't know what we're supposed to do about that.
I don't know if they'll give us free points or not.
Message, message, message.
I said Anubis is bugged and they ignored me, so.
Just do the other bosses then.
All right.
Working on it.
I'm going to try to make a holding pen somewhere.
Well, rest in peace.
is really big actually it requires quite a lot more room
than i think we have to work with uh just put it at a
different base than like yeah yeah yeah yeah actually that's
a good idea because we need to put 20 anyway in there yeah
good good point all right i'm gonna go to the anubis base
okay anubis is back up nice scary i'm gonna go quick all
right wait i forget what element earth is weak to what do i
need for the thing let's see How much time do we have left?
We have 17 minutes.
Do you need to trip for it?
Do you think we could do the Tower 3 together or now?
Peladium.
Probably.
How much more points do we get for that?
Tower 3 is...
That's 150 points.
Okay.
I can do that after I kill Anubis.
No.
I need to figure out...
Well, I need to kill this one too.
This other...
The fucking...
Where the fuck is this, Bob?
It's on the other island?
Guys, where's the botan?
Is it on the other island?
It's on the other fucking island.
Oh no.
What?
Are you level 50 yet?
Sure for?
No, if I kill some more bosses, I probably will be.
Okay.
I don't think I get levels from the...
What?
You get levels from the tower bosses?
Uh, yeah.
You do.
Oh, you do?
Okay.
Building the holding pen.
Should be close now.
I'll put in as many humans as I can Lily, do you have humans
on you?
I have a ton in my box.
Yeah, yeah, can you go to where Pee-Pee is and then put some
humans in there because we need 20?
Let me just on my way catch this Lutmon.
Wait, I think I already got it.
They're all just fucking passed out.
I don't think I can do anything to them while it's
nighttime, but we can just throw them all on the ground and
that should be good enough.
One, two, three, four, five.
Wait, we can only put 15.
How are we supposed to put 20 of them in there?
Wait, what?
Anubis has been caught.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Oh, you put them here!
Okay, wait.
Yeah, never mind.
We're good.
Okay, I can...
They all just fall in.
Yeah.
Clip, clip, clip, TP mod, Anubis.
That's wild.
Do you know where...
Are you able to get to that dungeon place?
Because I can just TP there and do it.
What, tower 3?
Yeah, the tower.
I don't know where tower 3 is, though.
Oh, wait, sure.
Do you have any humans you can put in this box since you're
right behind me anyway?
I mean, I got the black marketeers.
Yeah, just put them in there because we need...
How many more do you guys need for 20?
Uh, right now, I...
Oh, we only have, uh, 6, 7, 8, 9.
We've got 9.
9?
I have 8 on me.
I just want... I need to kill...
Oh, sorry, we've got 10.
Yeah, you can just put them in here.
Okay, I have 8 on me.
But I need... I won't kill this one.
Oh, my goodness.
I might just go to the tower then.
Yeah, you go to the tower.
I'm gonna do...
Find the fucking last boss here for medium.
Well, we'll leave our 10 humans in there for right now.
It's right here.
Okay.
You're here somewhere.
Yeah, whoever puts the last human in, just clip it.
Okay, it'll be me.
Wait, P.P., I don't know.
Wait, where you at?
I don't see you.
I'm at the Anubis base.
The fuck is the last guy.
Wait, why doesn't that show where you are?
That's so weird.
Oh, because I'm bugged right now.
Oh.
Yeah.
Come to the Anubis base and then don't use the pale box.
Use the actual...
cage.
Just come over and press X and you can put him in there.
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna go kill Botan.
One.
Two.
Keep thinking you're talking about Yu-Yu-Hakusho every time
you say it.
Alright.
Holy shit.
Oh, dang.
That's some cute humans!
What number are we at now?
I can't see.
It's kind of buggy for me.
It doesn't really show it.
There's a raid apparently.
12, 13.
Wait, 12, 13.
Wait, wait, wait.
12 13 14 15 16 17 we still need three more at the 10 minute
mark we have to butcher the chickens
okay wait wait a minute six 12.
okay i need four more piles to get 40 caught yeah we need
three we need three more humans i killed lily already i
already did it that's tower two wait where the fuck's tower
three is a volcano i'm gonna leave here i don't want to
fight die you get i guess so yeah tower 2 was lily okay we
need three more humans and we're good okay yeah i have three
that's fine i'll get it over there all right uh it's being
raided i just kind of left wait if it's raided then they
could they could destroy the human pen oh well i can't fight
all of them oh no okay i'm almost done oh no oh no
Please hope.
I thought maybe if I left they just wouldn't be interested.
Oh, that's a funny point!
So the four.
Oh my goodness.
That's right, that's a.
That's a hundred points to catch it.
I can't defend the base.
They're destroying the mailbox.
Oh, this is not correct.
I don't really know what to do.
There's like, You just leave.
If you just leave, they don't attack anything.
Yeah, just leave, just leave.
I got it!
Nice.
Quick, quick, quick, quid.
Quick, quick!
Clip, quick, quick.
Uh, they're chasing me, um...
Just teleport away, like, too long.
I got too far away from the paddle box, so I'm just gonna
fly away now.
Ah, fuck!
Alright, I'm dead.
Well, you know what, it's fine.
I saw it, I saw it.
Clip, clip, clip!
I got Botan!
Clip, clip!
Alright.
Okay, they all left our base, it looks like.
So...
Okay, I'm gonna head over and put the...
Let me find a...
Humans in?
travel yeah i need to find a fast travel right now awesome
and then i can do it yeah and then just clip it while you're
there see stupid little all right submit already be cod are
you still catching the lucky power just regular power i got
that lucky power okay i was gonna be like oh no i don't pp
mods is clipping and submitting my stuff i think so thank
you pp mods i know where that we're in fourth place nice i
know where that last dungeon is i'm pretty sure but do we
think we can get it done in 10 minutes if you can find the
dungeon and build the base in time i know where it is i'm
pretty sure how many points is that dungeon that dungeon is
uh 880 880 180 180 180 under minus blocked off where it
usually i think it is false alarm all right i am heading
back right now it's the 10 minute mark so we should why are
you doing tower three right now sure for what are you doing
well i have to go get to it i'm either gonna do tower three
or the other boss which is better points well bosses is like
70 and 65 tower three is 100 and oh my
but the thing is if i kill the bosses i know i get level ups
but you're 100 sure you get xp from tower bosses i'm because
i'm really close to 50.
um well if it's faster to do 50 palace 120 points um then
cat do the hard bosses then because then you can yeah just
do the hard bosses i'm gonna head over back now and put the
human okay i'm taking a look at my list uh forget what the
tower even Let me see what I can do.
Yeah, just do boss bosses, sure for.
I'm going to head over and try and get to the base.
Oh, no, my vanworm's starving.
Fuck.
Okay, I think...
Yeah, let me check my registered Pokemon.
Do you guys have food at the base?
Because I really need food.
Yeah.
We need 200 more points for third place.
Well, we're going to get some...
Here, check the cooler.
I just put a bunch of food in there.
I mean, we're about to hit a bunch of free points from...
Me hitting 50, butchering the chickpeas, and then human.
Yo!
Okay, I am heading...
Which base...
Where is the fuck?
Is it the...
Cooler, normal base, but we also need you to put in the
humans.
Yeah, I'm putting humans.
How do I put the humans in?
Do I just...
You walk up to it and hit X.
I die.
How many do they need?
I'm so close to my 40 piles, man.
Okay, I'm putting more than three.
They're all going to be in there.
Clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip, clip, there's definitely more than 20 now.
On my end, clip, clip, clip.
Viewing cage.
We'd like two more.
My team is starving.
All right.
We're so hungry.
They're so, they're so hungry.
I'm too busy clipping, but they're so hungry.
Let me see Lyft Monks if I can get anything on that, but I
don't think so.
You need to be back by three minutes if you can, so we can
do the chickpea.
How much time we got?
Well, I just died to like a bug or some shit, so I'm here.
Okay, let's do the stream now.
Okay.
I need a butcher knife.
Wait, what is Lyft Monk?
I really need to get back and fucking try and get that shit
back.
No, there's no way I'm gonna get the- Okay, let's get the-
I'm getting the butcher knife.
We got- do we don't have- Let's give me the butcher knife
real quick and then I'll do it.
I can make butcher knives.
Can you make- Yeah, just give me one.
I'll do it real quick and then I need to try and kill that
boss.
Okay.
I'll make four butcher knives.
I'll make one so I don't have to- I'm getting the chicken in
my pal box right now.
I'm making two.
I have a chicken in my pal box.
Meat cleavers.
Do we have to do it all at the same time?
Let me see.
Where is it?
All teams must be within this mansion mantle of chickpea.
I think so.
We should all get together then.
Okay.
Meat cleavers.
Yeah, we'll have to do it at the same time.
In the...
The barrel?
We need to do this fast because I need to go get my shit.
Get barrel, barrel, put in barrel.
Put in barrel.
I'm trying.
It won't.
Okay, there we go.
All right, cleaver and barrel.
I got one.
Put that.
Get someone get the other second cleaver and barrel.
I'm going downstairs.
Let's all go downstairs when you're ready All right, cleaver
and barrel.
I'm trying to Okay, let me know when you guys are ready.
Oh, I got to get a chicken And can I have your fire armor
after this?
Yeah, I can I give you my fire armor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Okay, I got how do I cleave them?
Put in your inventory put in your inventory and then for and
butcher Butcher wait for yeah ready wait.
I have it in my inventory, but I don't have a butcher option
holding it You have to yeah hold it hold it Wait hold it.
I can't I can't you you you drag the butcher knife into your
weapon.
Yeah I put it in your weapon slot.
Yeah, time is up there since I need to get level 50 Put it
in the weapon slot What do you mean you just drag it there?
Uh, give me your give me your armor Yeah, fuck.
Okay, we're guess we're all right here Bugs or some shit.
Yeah, we're not guess.
We're not butchering the chicken You guys are bug you guys
might not have to re-log you have to re-log just re-log and
then sure for do his thing Just re-log Like there's no other
way to explain it other than just put it in your weapon slot
It's the only way we can play it.
That's literally all you do What do you mean?
Were your pick that?
You're literally bugged.
You have to re-log Okay, I'm joining Okay, we're taking two
damn long.
Yeah, yeah, he can get like four achievements done right now
So we're letting him get do his setting wheel the knife drag
it over your pickaxe.
I'm drunk.
Okay, just just throw your pickaxe away Yes, it does.
Yeah, the screenshot is all four of them It's working now.
Okay, yeah, it's working.
Oh, yeah, it's working quick just have to wait a bit you got
the way for it okay i'm gonna like look upgrade go get the
go get the human thing while i'm i did i did the human
already how did you make it work you just realized and now i
can't put it in my just re-log can it properly really just
really still haven't re-logged what do you mean put it in
your weapon slot
i did i'm here the slot you're holding the slot you're
holding the crossbow in just drag the butcher knife in there
instead.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, I have... No shot.
We gotta wait.
We're just waiting for sure for him to do his thing.
I have it.
I got the butcher.
I got it.
Oh my god.
I have it.
Is there no way I have to catch Pals to register?
You can't drop at all?
I'm missing two Pals, ma'am.
Okay, wait, I've got it, it's there.
It's not working anymore.
I got it, I got it.
I got it.
I have also PPD mod.
Yeah, I got it.
Yeah, PPD mod.
Clip, Clip, Clip.
55 registered.
I get what you mean now.
I was trying to put it in my actual...
No, you went the butcher knife.
I was trying to put the chicken in my fucking weapon slot.
No fucking way you're thinking that, Brennwhat?
sedan dice!
How the fuck do you put it in the weapon slot?
Okay, we just wait.
We just wait.
He's just gonna do his thing.
PP mod.
Clip my clip clip clip clip registered 55 clip clip clip.
If I steal.
Can you make another butcher knife in case I die again?
Yeah, we have three minutes here for it.
Do you think you can get do it in three minutes?
Lily, how many how many pals do you have registered?
38.
I'm a thing to leave.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You should probably, all you need is, what, two more?
Two, take this money.
I'm going to drop this money.
I'll just like kill myself after I get this guy.
The black market guy.
I'm going to make another bushy knife for you just in case.
He's in the cage.
I'm going to need one if I'm killing myself.
I don't know if we have guys, but yeah.
Okay.
But if you can, go to the Anubis base and just buy two pals.
I'll manage, I'll manage, I'll manage.
Either that or go to the regular, go to the regular, would
be faster just go to the regular village all right doesn't
matter they're okay jesus all right i'm throwing pokeballs
at him now all right all right two minutes you got this your
four i believe in you jesus no shot did you get it i don't
think that sounds like last ball
Bullshit.
I guess I just have to kill him then Does do we get we don't
get points for killing him though?
We do.
Oh, we do?
Okay, okay I mean, I think so.
I think they made a new rule for them I have enough money to
buy everything!
Yay!
I don't have enough money.
I have money.
I can give her some.
Okay, go go go drop money.
Yeah, I'm going over there.
I'm so close.
You guys need to show a pal ducks.
I got it.
You're good.
It's right there.
right here 40.
you're good what did he go what did i got i dropped it i
dropped it in front of you no where is the market marketeer
right here in front of you where's the butcher knife from
you okay i'm going over i'm coming over we have one minute
close to level 50 i'm ready to butcher okay where's it
where's the knife i'm i'm here i'm here i'm coming over to
give it to you i have to travel back to lily here one minute
let's go all right all right let's do it let's go okay lily
gotta come back we gotta go downstairs and butcher this
chicken finally i'm downstairs All right, here we go.
Three, two, one, two, one.
Go, butcher!
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
All right, there we go.
All right, got it.
We got it.
Show your pal sex.
It's right there.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
Lily, show your- Tripper, you have one minute to get to low
50.
It's right there.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Let's go.
40 registered.
All right.
How the fuck am I gonna get to level 50?
What can you do in one minute or 30 seconds?
36 seconds.
I can kill a boss.
Okay, I don't think we can get that in 30 seconds.
I just need to kill like a semi high level boss.
I don't think I need armor and shit.
He has 26 seconds here.
Here's some pell armor.
I don't think he can.
20 seconds drop.
Also, I don't think anybody got this, but check your lift
monks as well.
I don't think we can got this.
Yeah, I have no final countdown show sure for did you show
your pal deck I'm trying to get a little 50 first goddamn it
minutes we still have the five minutes after we can do that
No, but that's reporting Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's you can
report your pal deck during it.
Yeah, oh it's ding ding ding Satch you your statue your
statue you actually no never mind is it over.
Yeah, it's over it's over Ding ding ding ding ding.
We were so cool close to 50.
If only I had more balls, man.
I would have had it.
I'm sorry, man.
Check your pal deck.
Pal deck time.
I showed mine.
Show your deck.
Ding, ding, ding.
I already did it before, but here.
The pal deck.
That was clutch getting the 40.
Let's go.
I mean, am I allowed to use the statue to see how many lift
monk I went to?
We have to get to like five.
I'm not a five for 10 points.
I'm at four.
Yeah.
I did not if i'm allowed to enhance yeah i think so right
for reporting yeah you should yeah you should be fine just
yeah it's just reporting i'm at i'm at three actually i'm at
four yeah none of us are five is where there's points five
is where it starts yeah all right i have 71 registered pals
71 showed clip clip clip clip clip clip mine's 40 already
clipped clip clip clip clip 55 we're tied for third 55 clip
clip clip they're still tallying though so we could be at
push down yeah it's true yeah you know what though you know
what though we did we did we did pretty well we did pretty
fucking good we could only i got 150 man we almost got 120
men level 50 and eight hours though that's that's kind of
that's kind of crazy if if somebody could have did it but
the i would have gotten 70 points in the blasphemy but it
failed the second thing and then i would for 120.
Oh, yeah, I'm checking what other stuff we can.
RNGs is not with me.
Yeah, our RNG was pretty fucking bad.
And I had to use the legendary balls in the black.
We just had it.
The black mark appears worth it because 180 points, so.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Alright.
71.
Did you...
Okay, I'm trying to check if they did all of us.
And Lily got hers, too.
Wait, Lily got hers.
40 it says 38 though No, I got 40.
How long?
Yeah, do the new register.
PP do the new one because like that says 38 New register 48.
Yeah, 40 High five Lily.
Oh my god, Lily we did it.
We just threw money at you like go by the last five minutes
We're just screaming at each other Throwing money at me and
screaming at me It didn't show the butcher thing, so I
restarted, but then you guys were like, put it in the slot.
And I was like, well, how the fuck do you put him in the
weapon slot?
I'm sorry.
I died to a fucking bug, man.
I would have been 50 if not for the bug.
You're lucky stats, man.
You're luck stats.
Let me see if I can find the clip of how I fucking died.
It makes no sense.
Just be like compensation points, please.
Yeah, like I would have gotten 50 if not for that shit on
God.
Why?
It's actually wild.
Check your balls.
You should have checked your balls, man.
Dude, what does this have to do with balls, man?
You ran out of balls!
You know the house rule!
The house rule!
You check your balls before you leave!
Oh yeah, we should log out.
Oh yeah, PP mod, PP mod.
40, 40.
You didn't give her check the registered 40.
Did you check?
Wait, technically...
Tell Lily to show decks.
Lily, show decks.
I love Shara.
Hold up.
Does the level sync matter with pals?
Because technically my pals are level 50.
Wait, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's the last one.
That works, report, report.
Oh, fuck it!
It works, it works!
It works!
Take a photo, take a photo, take a photo!
Yeah, it just has to be not you level 50.
I have the tanks, no, I have the tanks open for so long!
Open to decks!
Okay, hold it.
Show the level 40, because we still have...
Yeah, yeah, we still have one minute, PP mod, please.
Also, we need, we also need the clip of, uh...
Sureforce, level 50.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm just looking at it.
Someone can screen share.
Sureforce, okay.
I will fucking go over there, look.
at it keep it my keep it open i'll screenshot myself thank
you so much please clip wait no that's level 40 oh wait
level sing okay that's what i'm saying the levels can't
matter yeah level 50 sure for uh 50 sure for pet pal level
50 kind of is the name of the clip pal
No, get rid of that!
They're not gonna watch the clubs anyway, just get rid of
it!
Call it pal is level 50.
So fucking Giga Chad.
The Chad is fucking pal.
It's chaos!
Log out, log out, I'm logging out, I'm logging out.
Logging out, logging out, logging out.
Logging out.
Holy shit.
That was like the most stressful last- That was so
stressful.
Holy shit.
Bro.
Dude, we did so good.
We did so good though.
okay watch this clip explain to me how i died okay i'm
watching i need to know now i'll put the clip wait where's
the cut i put it in the team dokey bird is it i'm like i'm
sure everyone's like what hon i'll pull up the clip for chat
in a second what wait yeah what the fuck killed you i don't
know that's what i'm confused about huh okay i'm trying to
give you what killed you killed you wait were you on fire
maybe and it didn't register give me a second fire damage
doesn't tick that fast for all yeah that was really fast
like the fire oh here oh chef's on namus mode guys give me a
sec yeah i'll show chat i have an on mode on so people don't
track you down where i'm looking at it here you go there it
is it just dies he's just fucking collapses just Yeah, he
just collapses.
It's literally the dead Lollamote.
He's in the background, he's here, so he's clipped, clipped,
clipped.
Huh?
Holy fuck.
I'm gonna check the rankings right now.
so fucking stressful.
Holy shit.
It's actually so stressful.
You know what, though?
Trust the process, right?
We said it was going to be slow at the start and big gains
at the end.
That was way too stressful.
Not gonna lie.
That was really sad.
Trust the process.
All people had to do.
We would have been so much better if people just trusted us.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
I went process the whole time.
You know, that's right.
We trust it so hard.
We trusted so fucking hard trust go.
Oh my god.
It's so close third and fourth place Over and over again
third and fourth place is so close Oh my god I'm gonna pull
this over a second take a look at third place for zero
What's the word Set up like we didn't set up anything we
just went in blind we didn't balls deep We just went in
blind Try harder before they didn't give it to me.
It didn't count it.
Oh, it really says level 50, man It says level 50 It says
level 50 pal No It says the pal has to be level 50 nothing
says it's connected to player level Exactly
Okay, what about my bug dying randomly admin?
It says pal level 50 It's our fault.
It's not our fault.
Turf was too weak for his pal.
We.
He's not your pal level 50.
It's not our fault.
His pal isn't...
Objection.
Admin.
Oh, we got a second.
We got it.
We got an at.
Objection.
There we go.
Give us that point.
It doesn't change our placements.
But like... It doesn't change our place we set up wait does
it not wait how many points wait no it does it does we would
be second yeah yeah no no no if it does is we're third
because um they they they just went in front of us they just
yeah we would be third yeah yeah yeah yeah this does matter
this is technicalities right now yeah if we get it we are
third we are getting it it literally says power level 30
nothing yeah it's it's it's corresponding it has to be
exactly with player level 50.
yeah we're the people admin hate feels good no we're now
right now um actually right now right now ryan higgas team
is like 20 points ahead of us so we need that point we need
it we need it We really need it.
Come on.
Bro.
Bro, come on.
Count it.
There's no mention of player level 50.
That's a whole different achievement.
That's a different achievement for a reason.
That's a different achievement.
If they wanted it to be PAL and trainer, they would have
clarified in the rules, but they didn't.
It would have been one achievement for more points, but they
split the achievement.
Objection!
Yeah!
Take him to coin mine!
I'll take him to fucking coin!
Give us those sweaty points!
I'll point fingers and scream and they will take me serious!
At this point, we lost, we lost the sure fortune two bugs!
They should give us- No, no, no, no, actually, actually,
what do we do about- Three bugs, technically.
Actually?
Yeah, what do we do with the fangalope when I want to?
Yeah, three bugs.
Yeah!
Three bugs.
Come on.
Dude, why am I constantly getting fucked?
At least someone's getting it.
God, I fucking wish.
Wild.
Level 50 or bust.
Give it to us.
Come on!
She's a coward.
The mod's not coming over.
They don't want to fight us.
How like the Karens in the dokeybird chat need to be left
alone.
Give us those 20 points!
We want those 20 points!
I'm not asking anymore.
We're demanding right now.
It's a demand.
Would you like to return to your wife and kids safely
tonight?
Bro.
They're not giving it to us Oh my god, they're ignoring us
What?
Okay, let's I told you, man Someone at Dead Curson be like
question mark Ask Dan Clancy for a review I'll bring it up
Monday I'll bring it up at the dinner I'll be like Dan I
didn't get my third place at the rivals That's money That is
money right there That we deserve We deserve it!
Oh, we wait, they're typing!
They're typing!
Oh, they're typing!
We deserve it!
Come on!
Give us the point!
Look, I'm a Vtuber, I can't read, but I can read the word
pal, and that's all it said.
They deleted it.
They stopped typing!
They stopped typing?
They're ghosting us!
Yeah, I'm gonna do it again Typing again, typing Typing
typing typing typing typing Oh, oh, oh Where is it?
Come on We want to do it Give the others that point too We
don't care We deserve it Everybody deserves those points
Come on No!
Yeah, but that's a red number That doesn't matter It doesn't
Yeah, but it doesn't mention cap It isn't a cap So what?
Nothing mentions cap Nothing mentions We have a separate
achievement for player level.
What's the point then?
What the fuck's the point?
Yeah, what the fuck's the point?
We're being robbed.
We're being robbed right now.
We're being such huge carrots at the moment.
That's our third place.
That's our third place right there.
It's a dire wolf.
There was no way we captured a level 50.
dire wolf we leveled at fairish show me a level 50 dire wolf
and i'll show you a god there is no such thing pepe hands
we've been scummas we've been scummas unbelievable if you
don't make the rules proper we deserve the points that is
the mistake for next time that has to be fixed they did
count they did count the pack 20 humans right They did.
They should have.
Yeah.
I think half points at least is a good compensation.
Oh my god.
At least half.
At least half for when my fangle at the end.
I put a woo at the end so they can't get mad at me.
It's illegal to be mad.
It's internet girl magic.
Can we get partial points for when?
I just learned how to read, but it doesn't say cap.
All caps so they know I'm serious.
I like how Fangalob is in cap because he Googled the name.
Because I copied and pasted it from the Google Doc.
Can we get partial points for my...
Fengalope.
Fengalope!
That's how they know I'm serious.
So sure if I wrote...
Oh my god.
Half points, please, because...
Fengalope.
Fengalope!
Oh, are you choking?
Bro.
Oh my god.
Give us those points!
Did we get a clip of the kill?
Okay, we did, yeah.
Yeah, we got a clip of the kill, probably.
We should have, yeah.
That should have been there.
Yeah, and then I walked up to Anubis and he was bugged and
then I had to kill him later.
Guys, we're not third.
Everything's against me.
That's why we're trying so hard to get these extra points.
Because if we get the extra points, we would be third.
No, we're four.
We literally need 20 more points.
Oh, my guys.
It's not about the money.
It's top three.
It's about bragging rights.
You wouldn't understand.
You don't understand, guys.
Because top three, third and fourth place gets the same
amount of money.
They get the same amount of to put pile tournament champion
top three in my file for at least a week i need that on my
twitter profile yes we can you know what you know what guys
we'll just put the freaking clip that's 20 points right
there that's 20 points that clip is 20 points yeah sorry
chat they're still Wait, he's not there.
Can I just say sure for?
I don't know who's making your clips, but they're very
sassiest clips.
Those are me.
Yeah, look at it.
It says clipped by.
You're sassy.
I am sassy.
I told you I've contained myself.
I played with great men.
Dang.
Because it's not about the money.
Third and fourth get the same amount of money.
Okay.
Ryan Higgins team got more points.
I don't think we can go.
Oh, they got more.
Oh, no, no, we can if we get them.
No, no, no, no.
And we get the partial points.
How are they still getting more points?
Wait, how the fuck are they still getting more points?
The report is over.
I want to know how Team Garrick is six after they were first
from day one.
They did all, no, because they did all the global.
Oh, yeah.
They did all the global stuff in the day one.
They didn't have a good foundation.
They didn't have a process that was to be trusted.
We actually got the second most day two achievement points.
Let's go.
We just didn't get lucky pals.
I spent like six hours making that document yesterday.
Okay.
Can someone tell me how Zentrea's team got zero day two
achievement points?
They forfeited day two.
Like, if one of your teammates couldn't do a day two, so
they forfeited.
Oh, why didn't they just say a new person?
I guess, like, it's so last minute.
Maybe because, like, is Iron Mouse the host of the world?
That could have been it.
Wait, wait, they're typing.
They're typing now.
They're typing.
This is right.
Shut up.
Never invite Team Doki again.
Talk to you anymore.
Retourish a flesh man.
Stupid trash.
Why am I only judged by my...
flesh they're just like this fucking flesh tubing he must be
inciting them to why can't they be saying these fucking
pixels you're the one you're the one with like can we get
partial points for when fangelo what okay let me scroll up
and see all the pictures you guys posted and the objection I
needed I'm gonna take a photo of the
I actually curious what they're gonna say well apparently
Overwatch is on top because Flats and Siegel were on team
average Jonas's team oh shit yeah go overwatch too there we
go what the fuck were they doing I like how they stopped in
giga mode apparently they probably did all they probably did
all of those ones where you kill bosses with like the unique
weapons no they did lucky pals they literally have 10 lucky
pals no but they have they have they have uh almost 2 000
global achievements oh shit what the fuck we only have 1600
that's fine we had that's all right i can't believe it is it
said like and mention on broadcasts as well we how we be
watching the broadcast we're playing what the fuck do i
think i'm doing
it's like i think it says it's mentioned on the broadcast
and i'm just like we're playing at what we know
guys guys can you get the up i'm trying to watch the
broadcast guys please silence he a dire wolf though come on
he is a dire wolf
okay it's fine we got top five i can't believe it though
maybe top four top the goal was top five but with third so
close yeah yeah that's really funny that sure force luck
sure for it definitely has zero luck if i just wasn't
unlucky yeah sure for is actually zero luck if he wasn't
lucky we would have been top three holy shit
That's actually crazy.
You're fucking top four.
No!
It's not good enough!
It doesn't have the same ring as top three!
What the heck?
It doesn't sound good!
I know it doesn't sound as good on the Twitter profile.
How am I supposed to drag the fourth place on my Twitter
profile?
Come on, man.
My new title is top three asterisks if it wasn't for that
damn fangolo glitch.
it's okay we're top three in your hearts right chat in your
hearts we're top three right chat come on type one type one
of the top three type one of your top three okay i'm gonna
put top three i'm gonna tweet out top three i can't believe
we got top three in the power of the tribals my chat is
saying no my guys my chat is saying yeah you're not your
chat that's a Leave it.
Nobody asked.
They're saying last place in my heart.
Oh, last place in your heart.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
You can't believe.
You know what?
I'm proud of us, though.
We went from top 10 to top three.
Crazy.
Saw this from the bottom.
Now we are.
We went from the top.
We were top two easily.
Yeah.
turtles man it sure fort didn't get bugged like 500 times we
should get extra points from me having to figure out a new
strat during the first half yesterday because of paint oh
yeah a couple pity points to get to top three easily you
aren't kind of asking you for it yeah we just didn't have
kind of asking for it we just didn't have an east coast
person here unfortunately
well i'll just host next time it's okay yeah yeah next time
we'll No, thank you.
Yeah, we good.
No, thank you.
What the heck, guys?
I'm an FPS guy.
Pings all that matters to me.
It's my turn on the host bogs.
Denied.
No, move to NA for one.
Come to NA for Twitch Rivals.
I'll just play out real quick spontaneously.
Yeah, just fly out for like two days and then go do a PC
bang.
I'm not gonna let the person that just found out they were
on a 60Hz monitor host my game.
You know He's not right He's not gonna agree with him What
the heck?
He's not right I don't think Don't side with the fleshy I'm
a hybrid of everything A hybrid No The 60 Hertz gonna follow
me for a hard second It's clipped forever, Lily is there
forever.
Hey, GG's, guys.
I had a great time with all of you.
Seriously, amazing.
Thank you.
Yeah.
When we screamed at each other in the last three minutes.
Oh, that's what you meant.
I don't put the chicken in the weapon slot.
What are you doing?
The chicken in the weapon slot.
spot I can't believe it those 30 seconds actually those 30
seconds actually ruined your force like his luck went to
negative 100 after that I was on the second tick from
catching it and it fucking didn't capture well if it hadn't
bugged it wouldn't have been an issue because I was
literally on the like a moat wheel being like where's the
butcher one it's supposed to be here right and then I got
like hurt with confusion i was like what do you mean put the
chicken in the weapon i'm just like lock out lock the out
what do you mean put the chicken in the weapon slot i can't
you're it's cheat cheese everyone i'm so happy you guys were
all on my team thank you thank you for being good it was
really cool it was so fun thank you guys for joining the
Wait, Team, what was the fucking rap song again?
Team Vegeta?
I'm not a big fan of the government?
Yeah, team, I'm not a big fan of the government rap, Vegeta
and Vegeta.
Chat, chat.
I can't figure out what the acronym is for that.
What are all those letters?
I'm dyslexic.
What are those letters?
I'm a big fan of the government.
And DFTG?
I'm not stupid.
What?
BF Vap Vapna Bofager Vapna Bofager Team vapofager Let's go
Team vapna Bofager Let's go GG's guys I hope we Meet again
Into a TriVal I'll see you I'll see you I'm gonna go talk to
my chat now GG's guys Wait, are we confirmed?
We're confirmed for if we're confirmed I think so Yeah,
they're like You're third in my heart.
If you're not first, you're last.
We were never going to get first, you're four.
What do you mean?
You're fucking last.
Losers.
Chee-chees, guys.
I talked in my chat.
I'll see you.
See you.
Nice to meet you guys.
Bye-bye.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
My first Twitch rivals.
Doki we got top three Remember it was top three guys.
I can't believe it everyone top fucking three Plus one
Holy shit that was so fun when we started I still can't
believe in the last last three minutes.
We're just screaming at each other We were just like guys
Please!
It's your point.
I'm just yelling at PP.
Like, log out!
Log out for the love of God!
Just log out!
The fucking chicken!
The chicken that fucked us all!
Oh my god.
We got hard-fucked over by the chicken of all things.
The motherfucking chicken.
Oh my god.
The chicken and the weapon.
slot holy shit that was so fucking funny though oh my god oh
my god i swear i need to look at this how many points the
chicken even get us it was only 50 oh my god the chicken was
only 50 if we just let sherford do his thing if we just let
sherford do his thing we would never have to do the chicken
oh my god so much stress for 50 points oh my god oh my god
holy shit guys
oh my god it's like 2020 we were throwing for content to
make it or break it anyway guys had so much fun we just had
a lot of fun watching the content was worth it that's true
the content was worth it if it wasn't for that we wouldn't
have got the we wouldn't have got sure for this fucking can
we get partial points for when bangalope was playing we
would not have got that oh my god oh my god oh shit anyway
guys um for those who wondering if there's gonna be vods we
will i will be uploading vods of this um in like one to two
days i don't know or two to three days depending depending
on how i feel it's but we do have a vods channel now so do
not worry for those who are wondering we will be uploading
the vods um the vods for this um at later time because i
just made my vods channel i think it's called dokeybird vods
or some shit um but yes anyway everybody i hope you guys had
a great time um with us today i was i'm really happy with my
team with pp uh chad lily and surefort it was a great team
um where we all we all i was so worried because i was like
oh my god i'm the only one getting points at first i was so
worried but then the moment we were able to like have
everything like structured the moment we got everything we
need we just sped run so fucking hard on like so many
different achievements and the last hour it was actually
crazy the last hour we were just going bam bam bam bam bam
on the achievements we just needed to trust the process just
trust this process just setting everything up oh my god um
but yeah thank you guys um i'm gonna call it here thank you
all for all the subs all the gifted subs all the raids all
the bitties and all the follows if you guys are new here i
usually stream on the youtube so please check me out on
youtube um exclamation point stream over there i'm going to
be doing part three of batman tomorrow and uh check me on
twitter because i usually when i do stream on twitch i would
post updates on my twitter and finally if you want to
support me via other means dope exclamation point merch for
dokey merch um uh merch supports me a lot as well um so
thank you everybody i'm gonna call it here everyone as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody Bye guys.
Bye